GO AHEAD AND BEGIN THE.
.
HEALTH COMMITTEE AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
.
JUST SOME ANNOUNCEMENTS BEFORE
WE BEGIN WE WILL HEAR.
TWO WITNESSES PER SIDE.
WITH THE TOTAL TIME LIMIT OF
THREE MINUTES EACH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WILL BE ASKED JUST TO
STATE THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ON THE MEASURE.
OF THE FOLLOWING THOSE ARE
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBER MAY REQUEST
THAT A BILL REAMER BE REMOVED
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE FOLLOWING THOSE ARE FOR
CONSENT OUR ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
TWO ONE ONE TWO MISTER SANTIAGO.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR FIVE AB TWO TWO
NINE FIVE MISTER VOEPEL. I AM
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWO THREE SIX
SEVEN MISTER BERMAN ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB TWO THREE NINE SEVEN
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWO FOUR THREE
SIX WITH AMENDMENTS UP FOR MR
MATHIS.
A. B.. ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB
TWO FIVE SIX ONE MISTER FLORA
AND ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TWO
EIGHT ZERO FOUR. MISS WALDRON.
SEEN.
LOOKING AROUND HERE WE HAVE WE
DO HAVE AN AUTHOR MISTER KALRA
WHICH LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR BILL
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU BE
PRESENTING AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE CORRECT
IF I WAS TO LISTEN. START WITH
TWENTY TO THIRTY THREE I THINK
I'M SORRY HOW TO BILLS I
APOLOGIZE THINK I'M SORRY.
I DO AS CHAIR KNEW THAT THAT WAS
YESTERDAY OKAY SO.
PLEASE AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THIRTY THREE EXCUSE ME
TWENTY TO THIRTY THREE.
THANK YOU ASSURE MEMBERS.
AS CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE ON
AGING OVER THE FALL I HELD A
NUMBER OF INFORMATION HEARINGS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE INCLUDING
ONE IN SAN DIEGO. THAT WAS IN
REGARDS SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR
SENIORS AT HOME IN THE
COMMUNITY.
WAS OF THAT HER A HEARING THAT
WE LEARNED IN DETAIL ABOUT A
PROGRAM WHICH TAKES SENIORS FROM
A NURSING HOME. OF GOOD IT DOES
NOT CERTAIN NEED THAT LEVEL OF
CARE AND PLACE THEM IN ASSISTED
LIVING FACILITIES OR. ALLOW
SENIORS TO REMAIN AT HOME WITH
THE APPROPRIATE SERVICES. OR HOW
SOMEONE THAT'S AT HOME THAT
NEEDS TO BE IN SOME TYPE OF
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITY HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO.
IN THESE CASES.
.
THEY.
BENEFIT THE STATE BY BOARDING
THE HIGH COST OF A NURSING HOME
ESPECIALLY IS THAT LEVEL OF CARE
IS UNNECESSARY AND PROVIDES A
COSTUMES IS STATE IN DOING SO.
THE PROGRAM IS THIS IS A LIVING
WAIVER.
CURRENTLY THE DEMAND FOR THE A
LW PROGRAM HAS OUTPACED SUPPLY
AND OPERATES THE WAY THIS WILL
PROBABLY TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS FIFTEEN
COUNTIES.
ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORT SCORECARD ALMOST ELEVEN
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA'S UNDER
ONE THOUSAND NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS ARE ELEVEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS. ARE IDENTIFIED AS
HAVING LOW CARE NEEDS THESE
INDIVIDUALS COULD BE CARED FOR
AT HOME IN THEIR COMMUNITY WORN
ASSISTED LIVING CITING AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO LICENSE
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES. I HAD
VISITED.
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AND
HAVE BEEN TOLD US VERY DIRECTLY
BY SOME OF THE MANAGEMENT THAT
THEY WISHED AT ANOTHER PLACE.
THAT THE SOME OF THE PATIENTS
COULD GO THEY DIDN'T NEED THAT
COST ABOUT LEVEL CARE.
I HAVE A FURTHER MORE.
THEY'LL W. PROGRAM FACE NUMBER
CHALLENGES TO PREVENT THE
PROGRAM FROM REALIZING ITS
POTENTIAL INCLUDING LACK OF
AVAILABLE PROVIDERS. LOW
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AND HAMPER
PROVIDER PARTICIPATION LACK OF
STATEWIDE OF AVAILABILITY ND
INEFFECTIVE ADMINISTRATION A
MINISTRY OF REQUIREMENTS.
AND AB TWENTY TO THIRTY THREE IS
AN ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS ALL THESE
ISSUES AB TWENTY TO THIRTY THREE
WOULD INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
SLOTS AVAILABLE AND THEY'LL W.
PROGRAM BY UP TO EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED.
EXPAND GEOGRAPHIC REPRESENTATION
OF THE PROGRAM ON A REGIONAL
BASIS OUTLINED REQUIREMENTS FOR
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS. AND
CRITICALLY ADDRESS VARIOUS
PROGRAMMATIC ELEMENTS THAT
IMPACT ITS EFFECTIVENESS.
AB MEMBERS IS ONE OF THOSE
UNIQUE PROGRAMS AVOIDS THE HIGH
COST OF NURSING HOME STAYS SAVES
THE STATE'S. THE STATE MONEY AND
ONE THAT WE SHOULD EXPAND AND
IMPROVE.
ULTIMATELY THESE AND RISKY
BETTER CARED FOR AB PLUS CASA
PLACING PEOPLE IN A SETTING IN
WHICH THEY BELONG I'M VERY
GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR. AND
HIS PROPOSED BUDGET PRT PROPOSES
INCREASING AT THE SLOTS BY TWO
THOUSAND AND IN FACT THAT
INCREASE OF TWO THOUSAND SLOTS.
WILL BE SAVING THE STATE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BECAUSE
THOSE IN SKILLED NURSING WILL BE
GIVEN THE FIRST PRIORITY. AND SO
THIS PROGRAM EVEN BY INCREASING
IT.
IT IN THE THE YEARS TO COME TO
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
ALTHOUGH THERE WILL BE CASA BALL
DOES HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY ALSO
CREATE COST SAVINGS.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY I GEORGE
CANARIAN OF SIX BEDS AND AIR
CARLOS AND WOOD JUSTICE AN AGING
TO TESTIFY AND HELP ANY ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
GO AHEAD GRATED LIKE ABOUT IT.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS GEORGE
TICKNER AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING SIX BEDS WHICH IS A
STATEWIDE TRADE ORGANIZATION THE
REPRESENTS OVER TWO THOUSAND
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY. AND ADULT
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES SERVING
SIX OR FEWER PERSONS.
SIX BUT FACILITIES PLAY A VITAL
ROLE IN THE ALE W. PROGRAM
REPRESENTING APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
PERCENT OF THE HELD OF YOU
PROVIDERS. I'D LIKE TO START UP
I THINK IN THE AUTHOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA FOR INTRODUCING
THIS BILL.
AND CHAMPIONING THE ISSUE OF
IMPROVING THEY'LL BE PROGRAM.
THE PROGRAM'S YET TO SCRATCH
THE SURFACE OF ITS POTENTIAL KEY
ASPECTS OF THIS BILL WILL HELP
THE ELDERLY TAKES STEPS TOWARDS
REACHING THE POTENTIAL ITS
POTENTIAL IN A COUPLE OF AREAS.
FIRST INCREASING THE CAPACITY OF
THE PROGRAM TO EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED SLOTS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH GEOGRAPHIC
EXPANSION REPRESENTS A MAJOR
STEP TOWARD ACHIEVING GREATER
AND TIMELY OR CONSUMER ACCESS TO
THE PROGRAM.
EVEN IF YOU ADD ENOUGH SLOTS TO
THE PROGRAM TO ABSORB THE
CURRENT WAITLIST WHICH IS
APPROACHING THREE THOUSAND
PEOPLE. THERE IS NO MAGIC WAND
TO GET AWAY THEN INSERT
INSTANTANEOUSLY AND ROLLED THOSE
PERSONS ON THE WAIT LIST.
THOSE PERSONS HAVE THAT
APPLICATION SUBMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES WHICH THAT TO BE
REVIEWED AND APPROVED.
WE ESTIMATE THAT YES YES THE
PROCESS ON AVERAGE ONE HUNDRED
APPLICATIONS PER MONTH.
IT'S REASONABLE TO ASSUME THEN.
AS A RESULT TOO SOON AND THE
DEPARTMENT TO TAKE OVER TWO
YEARS TORO ALL PERSONS CURRENTLY
ON THE WAITLIST.
DURING THAT TIME ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE WILL BE APPLYING TO
ACCESS THE ALE W. AS THERE IS NO
PAS BUTTON ON DEMAND. SO ANYTIME
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT WAIT LIST
EVEN IF ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS LOTS
ARE EVENTUALLY ADDED DE EIGHT CS
FINDS ITSELF HAVING TO DIG OUT
OF A HOLE.
THE MOST NEGATIVELY IMPACTED ARE
THE MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES WHILE
LONG WAIT LISTS ARE PROBLEMATIC
FOR CONSUMERS OF ANY HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAM THERE
ESPECIALLY PROP PROBLEMATIC FOR
PROGRAM TO SERVE OLDER ADULTS.
WHERE REMAINING LIFE EXPECTANCY
IS OF REAL CONCERN? THE AVERAGE
LENGTH OF STAY FOR ELDERLY
PARTICIPANTS IS TWO HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN DAYS OR A LITTLE
OVER EIGHT MONTHS.
IF IT TAKES TWO YEARS OR MORE TO
PROCESS EVERYONE ON THE WAIT
LIST IT'S REASONABLE TO CONCLUDE
THEN THAT NOT EVERYONE ON THE
WAIT LIST WILL SURVIVE THE WAIT.
AND THAT IS A SHAME.
THIS IS WHY IT'S IMPERATIVE THE
LW STAY AHEAD OF THE DEMAND
CURVE AS OPPOSED TO LAGGING
BEHIND.
LONG WEIGHTLESS IS ALSO
DETRIMENTAL TO PROVIDER
PARTICIPATION.
WHEN THE A ALL OF YOU COME TO A
GRINDING HALT FOR AN EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME NEW PROVIDERS ARE
LESS LIKELY TO ENROLL IN
EXISTING PROVIDERS ARE LESS
LIKELY TO CONTINUE PARTICIPATING
OR WILL CHOOSE TO SCALE BACK
THEIR PARTICIPATION.
OFTEN CHOOSING TO USE THE LW
ONLY TO FILL THOSE NUMBER OF
BEDS IN THEIR FACILITIES ARE
CHRONICALLY VACANT. AND SHORT
UNLESS THERE ARE CHANGES
PROVIDERS WILL LOSE TRUST IN THE
PROGRAM.
ALSO AFFECTING PROVIDER
PARTICIPATION OUR REIMBURSEMENT
RATES
EXCEPT FOR THE MOST RECENT
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES TIGHT TO
SP THREE. LW PROVIDER RATES HAVE
BEEN STAGNANT WHEN THEY'LL BE
WAS LAUNCHED AS A PILOT PROGRAM
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX THE HOURLY
MINIMUM WAGE WAS SIX SEVENTY
FIVE. AS IT IT INCREASES SEVEN
FIFTEEN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN TO
EIGHT DOLLARS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT TO NINE AND TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AND TO TEN DOLLARS IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. PROVIDER
RATES WERE NEVER ADJUSTED TO
REFLECT THOSE INCREASES.
ONE ELDERLY PROVIDER RATE BECOME
UNCOMPETITIVE FACILITIES WILL
INCREASINGLY FAVOR PRIVATE PAY
CLIENTS OVER ALE W. CLIENTS.
IN CLOSING INCREASING THEY'LL
LOBBYIST CRISP CAPACITY
EXPANDING ITS GEOGRAPHIC REACH
AND INCREASED PROVIDER RATES
WILL CONTRIBUTE TO A MORE ROBUST
PROVIDER ECOSYSTEM. WITH AN
INCREASE IN BOTH THE BREADTH AND
DEPTH THE PROVIDER PARTICIPATION
IMPORTANTLY A MORE ROBUST
PROVIDER ECOSYSTEM TRANSLATES.
TO GREATER DIRECTLY TO GREATER
ACCESS AND CONSUMER CHOICE FOR
MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU.
SIR.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY MY
NAME'S ERIK KARLSSON I'M WITH
JUSTICE AN AGING OF THE
NONPROFIT.
BASED IN OAKLAND AND LOS ANGELES
THAT REPRESENTS INTERESTS OF
OLDER CALIFORNIANS AND. AN OLDER
AMERICANS I WANT TO SPEAK
BRIEFLY ON. JUST TWO OR THREE
ISSUES ONE IS TO POINT OUT OF
COURSE OLDER CALIFORNIA'S
OFTENTIMES. JUST PREFER
ALTERNATIVES TO NURSING
FACILITIES AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT IT'S ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT THE PUBLIC FINANCING.
STRUCTURE OF THE STATE DOESN'T
UNDULY FAVOR SENDING PEOPLE TO
NURSING FACILITIES RATHER THAN
TO COMMUNITY BASED SETTINGS LIKE
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY. AND THAT'S THE THE
RATIONALE BEHIND THIS BILL
THEIR.
SEE THE CURRENT CAP OF
ENROLLMENT IS THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE IN THE WHOLE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY JUST A DROP IN THE
BUCKET.
WHEN YOU COMPARE TO THE. TENS OF
THOUSANDS HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF AGING CALIFORNIA'S WE'RE
GONNA NEED SUCH ASSISTANCE.
WE SPOKE ABOUT THE FINANCIAL
SAVINGS.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ESTIMATES THE
ANNUAL COST OF NURSING FACILITY
CARE AT SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. IN THE ANNUAL
COST OF ASSISTED LIVING SERVICES
AT SIXTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY
SO THE STATE TABLE TO FUND FOUR
PLUS.
ASSISTED LIVING FOLKS RATHER
THAN ONE NURSING FACILITY PERSON
SO IT'S A WIN WIN FROM THE
CONSUMER'S POINT OF VIEW FROM
THE PROVIDERS POINT OF VIEW. AND
I RESPECTFULLY SUGGEST FROM THE
STATE'S POINT OF VIEW AS WELL.
AND THEN OF A FINAL MENTION
ABOUT SOME OF THE OF MAY BE LESS
PROMINENT PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
THE BILL ADDRESSES SOME
IMPORTANT LOGISTICAL ISSUES
RELATING TO THE TRANSPARENCY OF
THE WAIT LIST. AND THE.
.
THE EFFICACY OF THE FINANCIAL
STANDARDS IT SOMEONE WHO'S
WORKED IN THIS FIELD FOR LONG
TIME I CAN TELL YOU THAT EVEN
AMONG PEOPLE WHO. WORK IN IT
THERE'S A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT HOW THE PROGRAM IS
SUPPOSED TO OPERATE IN SOME REAL
DISCREPANCIES BETWEEN HOW
SUPPOSED OPERATE AND HOW IT
DOES.
AND IT THIS IS A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES IN THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS IN THE RENEWAL OF THE
WAIVER TO HAVE AN OPEN
CONVERSATION BETWEEN D. H. C.
OUTSIDE STAKEHOLDERS. SO THE
PROGRAM WILL WORK WORK MUCH
BETTER GOING FORWARD VERY MUCH
AGAIN VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT PLEASE USE
YOUR NAME AND.
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FRED
MADE ON BEHALF OF CAL PACE THE
PROGRAM FOR. ALL INCLUSIVE CARE
FOR THE ELDERLY. PROVIDING
INTEGRATED CARE SO THAT FRAIL
SENIORS CAN LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY. WE THINK THE
EXPANSION OF THE WAIVER FITS
PERFECTLY IN WITH THAT OUT
CALLING HIM WORD SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TO THIRTY THREE THANK
YOU.
HEATHER HARRISON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM LIVING
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JEFF HAMPTON LEADING IT'S
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
LISA COLEMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
ASSOCIATION WE WERE SO EXCITED
TO HEAR THAT THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WAS GONNA FORWARD THIS
BILL. I GET PHONE CALLS FROM
FAMILIES THAT ARE FRANTIC TRYING
TO FIND PLACEMENT. AND I ALSO
GET PHONE CALLS FROM SENIORS WHO
ARE FRUSTRATED LIVING IN SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES BECAUSE THEY
REALLY DON'T HAVE THE QUALITY OF
LIFE THAT THEY COULD HAVE.
AT COST SAVINGS TO THE STATE IF
THEY WERE ALLOWED TO LEAVE IN
ASSISTED LIVING SO WE CAN'T.
WE JUST CAN'T SAY STRONGLY
ENOUGH HOW MUCH WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
CAROL SUL FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING I.
ECHO LEASES COMMENTS WE THINK
THAT CREATING AS MANY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE TO STAY
IN COMMUNITY AS POSSIBLE. IS
DEFINITELY.
ECONOMICAL AND DESIRABLE THINK
YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
FOR A GOOD FOR THE WE HAVE
QUORUM SOMEONE TO TAKE GROW YOU
APPRECIATE THIS I AM I THINK.
I HAD A SECRETARY.
WENT HERE MAIN ST.
THANK YOU ARE CURRY. BONTA.
CARILLO.
BURKE. FLORA. LIMON.
MCCARTY. THIS AREA RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH THURMOND.
WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM GREATER. THAT.
REMOTE MOTION BY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ A SECOND BY MISTER
THURMAN FOR THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEM NOW WILL BRING BACK THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
MR CAR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND IN THE
VERY MUCH AS A SHARE MEMBERS I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND I JUST
KNOW TWO THINGS THAT.
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
INCREASED NUMBER OF SLOTS THAT
BY ITSELF WON'T SOLVE THE
PROBLEM. ABOUT UPDATE DAILY
MODERNIZING BUT.
THE SAUDIS BECOME. ELIGIBLE SO
IN THE PAST. FOR EXAMPLE MAY
REQUIRE A KITCHENETTE WHILE SOME
OF THE FOLKS ARE JUST LEARNING.
IT WOULD NOW THAT IT WOULDN'T
CAN EVEN USE ONE OR SHOULDN'T
USE ONE ANYWAY AND YET. POSE
SOME OF THESE OUTDATED
REQUIREMENTS ARE KEEPING US FROM
HAVING THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF
STOCK OF POTENTIAL ASSIST LIVING
FACILITIES SEKALI RIGHT NOW IT'S
FIFTEEN COUNTIES THIS BILL WOULD
EXPAND IT REGIONALLY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE'S OF THOSE KINDS I
DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE IT. WILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO HAVE
ASSESSMENT WE WERE PROGRAM IN
THEIR COUNTY SO WHAT THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT OF.
WELL I THINK YOU FOR BRING THE
GO FORWARD AND.
I OF I WOULD LIKE TO BE AT AN
APPROPRIATE TIME CONSIDERED BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR ON THIS
BILL I THINK I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
DOING IS IS.
IS VERY VERY MUCH NEEDED AND
THAT SMALL INVESTMENT WAS REAP
HUGE BETTER BENEFITS FOR
EVERYONE. THE PATIENTS AS WELL
AS THE STATE AND.
AND MORE IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE
GET THE APPROPRIATE CARE IN THE
PLACE THAT'S MOST APPROPRIATE
FOR THEM SO SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD.
WITHOUT A LAST MINUTES INTO THE
MANAGEMENT I.
CUT THROUGH THE OUT THERE BUT
YOU KNOW ME.
YOU LOOK LIKE ONE MAKE A COMMON
MISTAKE HERE CURRY.
I AM SO GLAD THAT YOU CONSIDER
THE ENTIRE STATE YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I HAVE A VERY GOOD FRIEND OF
MINE.
PAM A RODENT HAS EARLY
ALZHEIMER'S AND I KNOW THE
THINGS SHE WANTS TO DO IS BE IN
HOPES OF THE GROUND.
IT'S WHAT.
ANYONE ELSE NOW THAT I'VE VESTED
ALL APPEAR.
ALRIGHT SO SEEN NO NO CEMENT
SECTOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
AMEND SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WOULD I WOULD I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE AYE CARE CURRY
AYE ANGER CURRY AYE BONTA.
BURKE.
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA. FLORA I'M
AMONG.
MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH THURMAN THURMOND AYE
WALDRON. ONE I.
MOST OF TO THE BILL PASSES EIGHT
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES
RECORDED I TOLD YOU TO
APPRECIATE THAT WE DID WE DID
THE ROLE. TO HER. THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AT THIS POINT.
THE NET.
I'M SORRY ANOTHER BILL. YEAH.
SO I. TRIED TO DO THAT BEFORE
SO.
I WOULD SAY AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE THAT'S CORRECT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH VERY MUCH I
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
WOULD REQUIRE MANUFACTURERS TO
LIST ALL INGREDIENTS ON THE
LABELS PROFESSIONAL COSMETIC
PRODUCTS.
EXCEPT FOR THOSE PROTECTED BY
TRADE SECRETS
TO PROVIDE OPEN INFORMATION FOR
CONSUMERS LINE WORKERS AND THE
GENERAL PUBLIC.
IS IMPORTANT IN NO THE UNDER
CURRENT LAW PROFESSIONAL
COSMETIC PRODUCTS THOSE USES
LAUNCH ON A DAILY BASIS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO BE LABELED.
THIS BILL IS SIMPLY APPLY THE
EXISTING INDUSTRY LABELING
REQUIREMENT FOR RETAIL COSMETIC
PRODUCTS.
PROFESSIONAL COSMETICS.
BOB VITO COSMETICS ARE SOLD TO
THE PUBLIC FOR LIVESTOCK
CONSUMPTION.
SPECIAL COSMETIC PRODUCTS ARE
USED BY SALON WORKERS FOR
UPWARDS OF EIGHT HOURS PER DAY
RESULTING IN MANY CASES OF
ACUTE.
DISAPPEAR HEALTH SYMPTOMS
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
GIVE SALON WORKERS AND CONSUMERS
THE ABILITY TO VIEW INGREDIENTS
IN AN OPEN WAY THAT IS ALREADY
CENTER DIES. ACROSS OUR FOOD
HOME PRODUCTS AND RETAIL
COSMETICS.
SINCE MY INTRODUCTION OF THIS
CONCEPT LAST YEAR.
WE'VE REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION A
PROBABLY PURSUE THEIR SUPPORT OF
THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNCIL AND THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
FOR THOSE REASONS I ASKED WE AYE
BOAT AND WE'RE GONNA LEAD OFF
WITH. IP COULD MISTER CHAIR
CATHERINE PORTER POLICY DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY MEALS
LONG COLLABORATIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN WOULD
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I AM CATHERINE PORTER POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY NAIL SALON COLLABORATIVE
ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE.
IT CALLS FOR MORE TRANSPARENCY
AND THE CHEMICAL INGREDIENTS IN
PROFESSIONAL COSMETIC PRODUCTS.
THEY CALIFORNIA HOPING ELSE
ALONG COALITION IS.
GROUP OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AND JUSTICE AND WORKERS RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS AND INDIVIDUAL
NAIL SALON WORKERS AND OWNERS.
THROUGH COMMUNITY LEADERSHIP
PROGRAMS POLICY ADVOCACY AND
OTHER ACTIVITIES WE WORK TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH SAFETY AND
RIGHTS FOR THE PREDOMINANTLY
VIETNAMESE IMMIGRANT WOMEN WORK
FORCE IN NAIL SALONS.
EVERY WORK DAY FOR LONG HOURS
NAIL IN HERE SO ON WORKERS MANY
IF NOT MOST OF WHOM ARE WOMEN OF
REPRODUCTIVE AGE. YOU SOLVENTS
GLUES POLISHES STRAIGHTENERS AND
OTHER BEAUTY CARE PRODUCTS
CONTAINING CHEMICALS KNOWN OR
SUSPECTED TO CAUSE CANCER AND
REPRODUCTIVE S. RESPIRATORY
NEUROLOGICAL OR OTHER HARM.
THESE EXPOSURES ARE EXPERIENCED
ON TOP OF THOSE.
FROM THEIR OWN DAILY USE OF
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS SUCH AS
SHAMPOO LOTIONS HAIR DYES MAKEUP
AND MORE.
STUDIES SHOW THAT WOMEN IN THE
SALON PROFESSIONS ARE AT GREATER
RISK OF CANCER THAN THE GENERAL
POPULATION. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
ALARMING FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN
SALON PROFESSIONALS AS AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN GENERALLY
EXPERIENCE MORE AGGRESSIVE FORMS
OF CANCER. HEARING NAIL SALON
PROFESSIONALS MAY ALSO BE AT
INCREASED RISK OF CERTAIN
REPRODUCTIVE HARM SUCH AS LOW
BIRTH WEIGHT BABIES AND OF
RESPIRATORY PROBLEMS.
OTHER MANUFACTURERS ARE LEGALLY
REQUIRED TO LIST INGREDIENTS ON
THE LABELS OF COSMETIC SOLD AT
THE RETAIL LEVEL THEY HAVE NO
SIMILAR LEGAL OBLIGATION WHEN IT
COMES TO PROFESSIONAL COSMETICS.
THIS LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
HAMPERS BEAUTY PROFESSIONAL'S
ABILITY TO MAKE INFORMED CHOICES
ABOUT THE PRODUCTS THEY USE AND
MEASURES THEY CAN TAKE TO
PROTECT THEIR HEALTH. IT ALSO
GETS IN THE WAY OF CUSTOMERS
BEING ABLE TO KNOW ABOUT
INGREDIENTS USED IN THESE
PRODUCTS.
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FIVE WILL
FILL AND IMPROVE THIS LABELING
POLICY GAP BY REQUIRING THAT
MANUFACTURES LISTING GRADIENTS
ON PROFESSIONAL COSMETIC
CONTAINER LABELS.
WE AND OUR CO SPONSORS BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS WOMEN'S
VOICES FOR THE EARTH AND BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS.
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE KNOWLEDGE IS
POWER AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
REPRESENTS AN IMPORTANT STEP. IN
ENSURING THAT WOMEN AND MEN IN
THE CARE NAIL BARBER IN US
PETITION PROFESSIONS CAN BETTER
PROTECT THEIR HEALTH AND THE
HEALTH OF THEIR CUSTOMERS WHILE
AT WORK.
WE STRONGLY URGE A YES VOTE ON
A. B TWO SEVEN SEVEN FIVE THANK
YOU.
AND AND THE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR UPLAND BEFORE INTRODUCING
OUR FINAL WITNESS TO INTRODUCE
MANDY LEAVES HERE ON BEHALF
PERSONAL CARE POLICY COUNCIL FOR
COULD SUPPORT. AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS BUT IN THE
QUESTIONS AND I APPRECIATE THEIR
WORK FROM DAY ONE AND MAKING
SURE WE CAME TO A COLLABORATIVE
SO.
MISSION SUPPORT.
THE CBC'S.
UP THE I LIKE INTRODUCED TO YET
WHEN A LICENSE MANY MANICURIST
FROM.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY MY NAME
A STATE PLAN I MEET GREAT VICTOR
DE UNITE PICKS A FROM VIETNAM
EVEN.
TOOK PALESTINE BY.
I WILL RAISE A MANY THEORIES AND
FANTASY NOW SO LONG. ENOUGH RUN.
AND I ALSO LEAVE IT OPEN.
I HAVE LOOKED IN NOW SO LONG.
FOR PAYING YEARS.
I ASK NOT BE LOOKING IN NOW IT'S
THE LONGEST.
BECAUSE I HAD FRIENDS AND FAMILY
MEMBERS IN THEIR BEAST MODE.
AND NEW.
I COULD LEARN THOSE FIELDS
DOODLE AGUCHI UP.
WHEN I DECIDE MEET THE BE A MANY
THEORIES. ADMIT THEM NOW.
THAT EVERYDAY I WOULD LOOK WEAK
HOT FOR. CHEMICALS.
AND LOOK AT SOME HIGHS.
AND A LOOK SOMETIME A SPEEDY AND
HOPE THEY CATCH.
SCHEME REST SHE'S WHAT THIRTY
EYES.
AND EVEN COUPLE READING WISH MAY
BE RELATED TO THEIR PRODUCTS
IDEALS.
BUT IN THREE ENTITIES.
ON THE LABEL. UP A PROFESSIONAL
COST MAKING. IT I NOW PARTY'S.
HELP ME WHEN A CUSTOMER ASKS.
WHAT NO PUN LEAST CAMPAIGNS?
I CAN JUST SHOWED LET GO TO THE
CUSTOMER.
IT I GUESS SPEAK.
AFTER USING. UP ALL ABOUT IT
LOOK.
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
IF I COULD SHOW A DOCTOR
MERRILEES UP ADRIAN ON THEIR
LAND BOTH TILL SLOWED UP THERE
COULD HE GO AROUND WHAT WRONG
WITH ME.
NOW IS THAT NAM ALL KNOWS
AND WORKERS LIKE.
ME AND LEARNING MORE AND MORE
ABOUT HOW TO DEAL PUBLIC THANKS
OUT SEO'S.
FROM TOSTIG CHEMICALS.
IN PROFESSIONAL COSMETICS.
S. THIS EVIL INGREDIENT
INFORMATION. IS IMPORTANT FOR US
TO DO THAT.
FINALLY I SUPPLY ALL EIGHT BE.
TWENTY SEVEN A SAVER AND THE
FLAG AB CLOSE THE LINE WORKERS
EZOLA USE KNOW MORE. ABOUT THE
PRODUCT.
WE USE EVERY DAY.
BLAZE THEY'VE ALL YES.
ON A. B. DANTE SEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE THANKS AND THANKS SO MUCH.
MAKE YOU THINK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY MARINO ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
EMILY CHEN ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
CONNECTICUT THAT WORK IN
SUPPORT.
MELISSA MI BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
RYA SPENCER WITH AMERICAN
COLLEGE OBG WAYANS AND SPORT.
LEASE AT BENTLEY FOR BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS AND
ON BEHALF OF BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS IN SUPPORT.
JANET MIDDLEMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR SAFE COSMETICS AND
WOMEN'S VOICES FOR THE EARTH
ANOTHER OF THE BILL'S SPONSOR
AND PROUD SUPPORT.
MY CLOCK ON BEHALF OF ASIAN
HEALTH SERVICE IS OUT IN OAKLAND
AS WELL AS CLEAN WATER ACTION IN
SUPPORT.
AND FUND ON ROUTING INFORMATION
HEALTH SERVICES NOLAN I SUPPORT
THE TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN FIVE.
MY NAME IS GLADWIN I M. A MEDI
GORY. ES.
LUCY NOW SADDAM.
AT. AYE. LEVER EIGHTEEN OAKLAND.
I.
SUPPOSE.
A.
BE.
JOE SEVEN SEVEN FIVE PAYMENT
YOU.
EACH PATTERN MY NAME. AMEN MEG
HICKERSON.
AND AT LITTLE HEAD AND HAST
SEVERAL.
AND I AND I IT OPEN IT IN
UPGRADED. ACTUALLY BOUGHT. AB
TWO SEVEN SUPPORT THE PIE.
I ALSO LIKE TO SUPPORT.
UP FROM A STEP TO SCHOOL BAY
AREA PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY VOICES ON ME TOO.
AND OFFICIALLY FOR THE RECORD
MANUALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT IT'S NOT
INSIGNIFICANT AT THE INDUSTRIES
HERE SUPPORTING A BILL LIKE THIS
BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SO WE HAVE MOTION A SECOND BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANYONE
FROM COMMITTEE YES OF MISS MISS
CARILLO AND THEN A SMALL.
THANK YOU AND I THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS TO OUR
ATTENTION AND I LIKE TO THINK
THE WITNESS SAYS.
WHO ARE HERE IN SUPPORT AND WHO
PERHAPS ARE HERE FOR THE FIRST
TIME WELCOME TO THE PEOPLE'S
HOUSE?
I WOULD ESPECIALLY LIKE TO THANK
OUR THE WITNESS AT THE TABLE FOR
SHARING YOUR OWN PERSONAL STORY
OF WHAT IT IS.
TO WORK IN A NAIL SALON.
I AS LEGISLATORS WE DON'T OFTEN
HAVE A LOT OF TIME BUT ONE THING
THAT I DO FOR MYSELF A SELF CARE
AND THAT IS SO MANY PETTY.
WHENEVER I GET AN OPPORTUNITY.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THE WOMEN MOST OF WHOM ARE WOMEN
OF COLOR.
THAT ARE DOING THIS TYPE OF WORK
UNDERSTAND THE CHEMICALS THAT
THEY'RE WORKING WITH AND THAT WE
AS CONSUMERS ALSO SUPPORT THEM
IN THEIR EFFORTS TO HAVE.
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENTS IN WHICH
THEY WORK SO THANK YOU AND IF
IT'S ALRIGHT WITH YOU I'D LIKE
TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON YOUR BILL.
THIS WATER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ARM. BY
SUPPORTED THE BILL LAST TIME IT
CAME FORWARD ON UNDERSTANDING
SOME OF THE ISSUES.
I REMEMBER A COUPLE YEARS AGO
WHEN ONE OF THE HAIR STRAIGHT
STRAIGHTENING THINGS THAT WAS
THE ALL THE RAGE THEY FOUND IT
HAD FORMALDEHYDE IN IT AND A LOT
OF PEOPLE TO.
I KNOW THAT
IT BE NICE TO HAVE THOSE
PROTECTIONS YOU BOTH AS THE
PERSONAL CARE WORKER AS WELL AS.
THE.
CLIENTS TO BE ABLE TO KNOW YOU
KNOW MAYBE THEY SHOULD. HAVE A
MASK OR SOMETHING ON THE DO I
HAVE.
.
AND THE OTHER FACT THAT A LOT OF
THE FOLKS WHO WORK IN THE SALONS
ARE INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS SO
THEY DON'T HAVE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS. THE OCCUPATIONAL IN
SAFETY TYPES OF. PROTECTIONS
THAT WORKERS IN A NORMAL
INNOCENT EMPLOYEE WOULD HAVE SO
THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE THANK YOU.
AND YOU CAN ADD ME AS A CALL.
GREAT ANYONE ELSE IN THE
COMMENTS.
SEEN AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
MISTER CARR. BUT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND YOUR. MESSAGE TO
SUPPORT ACTUALLY APPRECIATED ON
A THANK EVERYONE THAT'S BUT
THAT'S HERE IN SUPPORT ALL THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL IN
PARTICULAR. CATHERINE PORTER AS
WELL AS ARE MANY CURIOUS.
.
AT THE END. SO PLAN ON KEEPING
IT OF FISHING YOU BEING HERE AND
DOT PERVERSE WHAT HE ASKED FOR
MY BOOK.
VERY WELL THANK YOU I AM WE HAVE
A MOTION FOR MISTER THURMAN A
SECOND FOR MISS WALDRON THE.
INDOOR IN THE DO ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR.
OF THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
SITES.
AMEND SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WOULD I WITH I MAIENSCHEIN I
MEAN CHEN AYE AYE GEAR CURRY. I
CARE CURRY AYE BONTA.
BURKE.
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA. FLORA I'M
LIMON.
MCCARTY NAZARIAN.
THIS AREA I APPROPRIATE.
SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WALDRON. WALDRON
AYE.
THAT'S EIGHT ZERO THAT BILL
PASSES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER KALRA. AYE WELL OUR NEXT
TO OUR NEXT AUTHOR IS MR MATHIS
I BELIEVE.
AND WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR THAT
WILL I WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION
IF ANYONE'S GOING TO ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
MOTION IS BY MR THURMAN SECOND
BY MISS AT YOUR CURRY
CONSECTETUER INCLUDES AB TWENTY
ONE TWELVE.
I DID THAT'S ITEM NUMBER THREE
AND NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY FIVE. ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY SEVEN.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT TWENTY THREE
NINETY SEVEN. ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY SIX.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY ONE. AND ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN HE BE TWENTY EIGHT ZERO
FOR SOME ITEMS
TERRY ANY MEMBERS HAVE ANY
CONCERNS ABOUT THE THOSE BILLS.
SEEING ONE OF SECRETARIES CALL
THE ROLL.
BUT THE MOTION AND EMOTION FROM.
.
MR.
BERMAN AGAIN AND THEN TO SAY
HERE CURRY.
WOULD I WITH I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE AYE CARE CURRY
FACTOR CURRY AYE. BONTA.
BURKE CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA. FLORIDA AYE
LOW MOAN. MCCARTY NAZARIAN.
AARON I RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO STEINORTH THURMOND.
BERMAN AYE WALDRON. MOTHER AND
I.
THAT'S EIGHT EIGHT ZERO SO I
WOULD APOLOGIZE I I SAW MR
MATHIS HERE FIRST AND SO I
CALLED YOU UP THIS EGGMAN YOU
ARE IT'S FILE ORDERED SINCE MY
APOLOGIES MISS.
ARE YOU OKAY.
THANK YOU MY APOLOGIES.
MY APOLOGIES SO.
I SEE YOU GUYS FOR A WEEK OR SO
AND I'M A LITTLE CONFUSED SOME
ANYWAY.
OF THE WAY MISTER MATHESON AND
TAKE YOU FOR YOUR ST SEGMENT.
YOU'RE PRESENTING.
.
FIND IT NOW.
ITEM THIRTEEN ITEM THIRTEEN AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY NINE. YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AND.
I LIKE START UP WITH YES I WILL
BE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS ON THIS
SHOW AND I LIKE TO THINK YOU'RE
STAFF UP FOR THE HARD WORK ON
THIS.
.
AS YOU ARE FAMILIAR WE.
WORKED ON THIS OF.
BILL LAST YEAR WAS E. V..
ONE FORTY EIGHT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I THANK YOU FOR.
.
BEING I LIVE THE LASHER
HOPEFULLY YOU'LL JOIN ME ON THIS
ONE THIS YEAR.
WE'VE TAKEN A FEW AMENDMENTS
WE'VE TALKED WITH AUNT PAT WE'VE
WORKED WITH.
THE SENATE.
COMMITTEE AS WELL AND WITH
CHAIRMAN.
HERNANDEZ OVER THERE. AND TO
REALLY GET THIS BILL RIGHT AND.
WHAT AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY NINE
DOES VERY SIMPLY IS IT TAKES A
REALLY GREAT PROGRAM THE STEVEN
THEM THOMPSON PROGRAM?
AND MOVE SOME OF IT TO HELP
ADDRESS THE DOCTOR SHORTAGE WE
HAVE IN RURAL AREAS.
TO BE VERY FRANK SIXTY FIVE
PERCENT OF OUR SCHOOLS ARE IN
RURAL AREAS IN THESE CHILDREN
NEED GOOD DOCTORS WHERE THEY'RE
AT.
AND
DUE TO TIME CONSTRAINTS I'LL
KEEP IT SHORT WITH THAT I'D
REALLY APPRECIATE AYE VOTE AND
ANYBODY ELSE WOULD LIKE TO COME
ON AS A CO AUTHOR OR A PRINCIPAL
AGAIN. THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH YOU HAVE A WITNESS.
YES IN THEIR PLACE AYE KELLY
BUCKS I'M REPRESENTING.
THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
TODAY.
ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
HEALTHCARE IN RURAL AREAS IS
DEPENDENT UPON AN ADEQUATE
SUPPLY OF HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS.
RURAL COUNTIES HAVE SIGNIFICANT
PROVIDER SHORTAGES.
FIFTY PERCENT OF THE PHYSICIANS
IN RURAL AREAS ARE OVER THE AGE
OF SIXTY AND WILL RETIRE REDUCE
THEIR HOURS OVER THE NEXT
DECADE.
ADDITIONALLY NINETY SEVEN OF THE
TWO HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN PRIMARY
CARE HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
SHORTAGE AREAS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
IN OUR THIRTY FIVE MEMBER.
COUNTIES ON IN FACT THIRTY OF
OUR THIRTY FIVE MEMBERS.
NUMBER COUNTIES HAVE PRIMARY.
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES AND TWENTY
SIX OF OUR MEMBER COUNTIES HAVE
FIFTY FOUR DESIGNATED MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS.
RESIDENTS ARE COUNTIES OFTEN
HAVE TO TRAVEL LONG DISTANCES
FOR SPECIALTY CARE SERVICES.
AND WE WE BELIEVE THAT.
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY NINE IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP TOWARD TRYING
TO ADDRESS ON THE ISSUES THAT
THE RESIDENTS OF RURAL AREAS
SPACE. I'M I'M ALSO HERE TODAY
AND SUPPORT.
FOR THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS
AND THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. ALEX HAWTHORN OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
BRENT AND MARK SHE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MOTION MY MISTAKE YOUR CURRY
SECOND AYE MR THURMAN ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
I SEE NO ONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS RESEARCH METHODS.
SEEING NONE.
WILL LIKELY HAD MUCH CLOSER
LIKENESS MATHIS.
AGAIN MEMBERS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AS ALREADY STATED OUR ROLE
THERE IS REALLY NEED THE HELP.
OUR DOCTORS ARE RETIRING WE NEED
NEW ONES.
AND THIS YEAR'S HELPS GIVE THEM
THAT INCENTIVE.
TO MOVE TO THESE AREAS THAT
DESPERATELY NEED THEM I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTES IN YOUR SUPPORT
LIKELY.
THANK YOU WITH MATHIS I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS IN
THIS AT SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS
WERE OF A VERY VERY RURAL
DISTRICT.
I'M ONE OF THE CHALLENGES AND
AND JUST YOU KNOW THAT THE
PROGRAM IS A IS A WONDERFUL
PROGRAM BUT IT IS ALSO. PRETTY
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND SO SO GOING
FORWARD YOU KNOW. THE RESOURCES.
MAY NOT BE THERE.
TO ACCOMPLISH EVERYTHING WE
WOULD LIKE HOWEVER.
AYE I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
I WOULD I WOULD INDEED LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU SO THE.
THE BILL DOES.
HAVE A.
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION OF THE
MOTION BY MISTER AGUILAR CURRY
THE SECOND BY MISTER THURMAN.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS MEMSIC
TERRY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WOULD
I WOULD AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAIENSCHEIN AYE. AGAR CURRY.
HACKER CURRY AYE BONTA. BURKE
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA AYE THE
MONIQUE. LIMON AYE MCCARTY
NAZARIAN. THIS AREA AYE
RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO STEINORTH. THURMOND.
BERMAN I WASN'T.
WALDRON AYE.
THAT HAS NINE VOTES AND THAT'S
THEM MORE THAN ENOUGH TO GET OUT
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
SOMEONE TO GET MORE FUNDING
THERE AREA I LIKE THAT.
THANK YOU FOR HIM HEADS MISS
EGGMAN.
MISS EGGMAN WILL BE PRESENTING
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COURSE.
I GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN MIGHT BE
ONE OF THE. LEAST CONTROVERSIAL
BILLS ALL PRESENT HEALTH
COMMITTEE IN MY CAREER.
I'D LIKE TO START OFF BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS.
AND THINK ALL THE COMMITTED
STAKEHOLDERS WHO BEEN A PART OF
THIS I'M PITCHING RIGHTS
ADVOCATES ENSURE THAT THE RIGHT
CIVIL RIGHTS OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING MENTAL DISABILITIES
ARE PROTECTED.
I'VE THEY REPRESENT MEMBERS OF
THIS MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION.
BUT THEIR TRAINING IS IT HAS
NOT BEEN CONSISTENT ACROSS THE
BOARD AGAIN WORKING IN SOME
RURAL COUNTIES PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
THE SAME AMOUNT OF ACCESS.
AS OTHER PLACES SO THIS BILL
SIMPLY.
THERE'S BEEN SOME DISCREPANCY ON
ON STANDARD SO THIS BILL SIMPLY
SAYS THAT WITHIN OUR NINETY DAYS
OF SOME BE STARTING IN UP IN A
NEW POSITION THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS. TO ALL OF OUR.
A CONSISTENT INFORMATION THAT
WILL BE UP ON A WEBSITE.
IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THAT
ANYONE HIRED AFTER TWO DOZEN
EIGHTEEN REPORT THE COUNTY THAT
THEY HAVE REVIEWED THIS
INFORMATION WITHIN NINETY DAYS
TO THIS KIND OF. CUTS DOWN ON
SOMEBODY JUST KNOWING SOMEBODY
WHO DESCRIBED A JOB TO THEM
VERSUS SOMEBODY WHO READ
SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND PROVIDES
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE STATE.
I'M WITH ME TODAY I HAVE A
CUSTOMER JOHN FROM A PRISON OF
CAMPER ENCOURAGE CHILD FROM THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
SHE.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTEEN AND THINK YOU DO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN. FOR
INTRODUCING THIS.
I AM WRITING THIS EMAIL JAN AND
I AM THE CURRENT PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MENTAL HEALTH PATIENTS RIGHTS
ADVOCATES WE ARE THE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE PROFESSIONALS
THAT WOULD BE IMPACTED BY THIS
BILL. OR ORGANIZATION SUPPORTS
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN.
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR
PROFESSION.
A CALIFORNIA STATE LAW REQUIRES
THAT EVERY COUNTY HAVE A
DESIGNATED PATIENTS RIGHTS
OFFICE AND OUR PROFESSION IS
INTEGRAL TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM.
WE REPRESENT PATIENTS
INVOLUNTARILY HELD IN LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS.
WE RECEIVE INVESTIGATE
COMPLAINTS OF RIGHTS VIOLATIONS.
WE PROVIDE TRAININGS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS TO STAY
COMPLIANT WITH REGULATIONS.
AND WE INSURE PATIENTS AND
LOCKED PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS ARE
INFORMED OF THEIR RIGHTS.
THE JOB OF THE PATIENTS RIGHTS
ADMIT ADVOCATE IS TO PROTECT THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MENTAL HEALTH
CONSUMERS.
THE GOAL OF OUR WORK IS TO
PRESERVE PATIENT DIGNITY AND
IMPROVE QUALITY OF CARE.
AB TWENTY THIRTY THREE SIXTEEN
WILL IMPROVE THE WORK OF COUNTY
PATIENTS RIGHTS ADVOCATES BY
MANDATING TRAINING REQUIREMENTS
FOR OUR PROFESSION.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE NO MANDATED
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS FOR OUR
KIDS PROFESSION AND ADVOCATES
COME FROM A WIDE VARIETY OF
EMPLOYMENT BACKGROUNDS.
IN A RECENT SURVEY TWENTY THREE
PERCENT OF PATIENTS RIGHTS
ADVOCATES STATED THEY RECEIVED
NO TRAINING AT ALL.
NINETY SIX PERCENT OF ADVOCATES.
WHO HAD THREE YEAR AT THREE
YEARS OR LESS OF EXPERIENCE
STATED THAT THEY DID SUPPORT
THESE TRAINING REQUIREMENTS?
AB TREE AB TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN
WILL ENSURE THAT PATIENTS RIGHTS
ADVOCATES HAVE A BASELINE LEVEL
OF COMPETENCY TO CONDUCT OUR
IMPORTANT WORK THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KURT CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA A
OUR OFFICE OF PATIENTS RIGHTS
pDEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
TO
PROVIDE THE TRAINING. THROUGHOUT
THE STATE FOR.
THE PATIENTS RIGHTS ADVOCATES
SO WE ARE OF COURSE ALWAYS
LOOKING FOR WAYS TO IMPROVE.
THAT TRAINING AND ENSURING THAT
WE CAN REACH MORE.
OF THE PATIENTS RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN THE RURAL AREAS
THROUGHOUT.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN THOSE
WHERE IT IS INDEED A PROBLEM TO
GET TO OUR AT IN PERSON
TRAININGS.
WHEN WE HOLD THOSE.
BY.
INCLUDING IN THIS BILL THAT WE
HAVE ALL OF THE TRAINING
MATERIALS POSTED AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE LOCAL.
PATIENTS RIGHTS OFFICES AND
WITHIN THE COUNTIES TO HAVE A.
CERTIFICATION THAT.
THEY HAVE LOOKED AT THOSE
TRAINING MATERIALS WE THINK THAT
WILL HELP IMPROVE.
THE.
SERVICES PROVIDED BY PATIENTS
RIGHTS THINKING
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RANDALL HAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE PSYCHIATRISTS AND
PATIENTS RIGHTS ADVOCATES WORK
TOGETHER TO COLLABORATE FOR THE
BEST INTEREST OF PATIENTS. AND
TO THE DEGREE THAT THERE'S
BETTER EDUCATION AND TRAINING
AND STANDARDS THAT COLLABORATION
BENEFITS THE PATIENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AFTER A SHOWER THE CALIFORNIA
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLANNING
COUNCIL WE ARE ACTUALLY CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND AND
WORKED A. LONG AND HARD WITH THE
CAMP FRIEND WITH THIS EGGMAN TO
GET THE STILL MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS IN ENGLAND.
I'D.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION THAT WE HAVE
A MOTION AND BY MR THERMOS
SECOND BY MISS BURKE OKAY AND
I'M WHICH LIKE CLOTHES MISS.
BURKE DESERVES AMPLE EDUCATION
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MOTION IS.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD I MEAN TIME.
MASON I AM HERE CURRY. FIGURE
CURRY AYE BONTA.
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA AYE LOW
MOAN.
THE MODEM. AYE MCCARTY AYE
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH.
THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WALDRON. WALDRON
AYE.
ELEVEN ZERO YOU BILLS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF A SEGMENT.
NOW I BELIEVE.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA WILL BE PRESENTING AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
I AM HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY WHICH IS A
BILL TO HELP TO AIM TO RAISE THE
INCOME LET LET LEVEL. FOR THE
AGED AND DISABLED MEDICAL
PROGRAM TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL.
CREATING PARITY BETWEEN SENIORS
AND DISABLED MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES AND OTHER ADULT
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES.
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF THE ACA
MOST ADULTS
THE MEDI CAL.
IF THEY HAVE AN INCOME BELOW ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT PERCENT
OF THE FPL WHICH IS JUST UNDER
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR FOR AN INDIVIDUAL.
THE ACA HOWEVER DID NOT CHANGE
THE INCOME LEVEL FOR THE MEDI
CAL AGED AND DISABLED PROGRAM.
WHICH IS A HUNDRED PERCENT FPL
PLUS TWO HUNDRED THIRTY DOLLARS
FOR AN INDIVIDUAL ONLY TWELVE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS
PER MONTH.
AS OF NOW THAT'S EQUIVALENT TO
ESSENTIALLY A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE. PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL.
THIS ALSO MEANS THAT A SIXTY
FOUR YEAR OLD ADULTS WITH FREE
MEDICAL.
CAN LOSE IT THE DAY THEY TURN
SIXTY FIVE YEARS OLD.
A SENIOR WITH AN INCOME EVEN ONE
DOLLAR OVER THE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE PERCENT THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL THRESHOLD. IS ONLY
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICAL WITH AN
EXPENSIVE SHARE OF COST.
THE ONLY WAY FOR THE SENIORS
WITH INCOMES ABOVE A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE PERCENT FPL. TO
ACCESS MEDICAL BENEFITS IS TO
PAY HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS IN A
MONTHLY MEDI CAL SHARE OF COST.
OF ABOUT SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLARS PER MONTH WHICH MANY ARE
UNABLE TO DO SO.
THIS CREATE A SIGNIFICANT
BARRIER TO HEALTHCARE FOR
SENIORS
TO ACCESS AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE
BECAUSE THEY ARE FORCED TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN. PAYING FOR RENT
AND FOOD FOR THEIR MEDI CAL
SHARE OF COST.
THIS FORCES MANY SENIORS
TO FORGO NEEDED MEDICAL SERVICES
COMPELLING THEM TO MOVE INTO
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AT
HIGHER COST TO THE STATE. AND AN
EVEN HIGHER PERSONAL COST
TO THEIR OWN INDEPENDENCE AND
WILL BE.
RAISING THE AGE AND DISABLE
INCOME LIMITS TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT PERCENT OF THE
FEDERAL PARTY LIMIT IS THE
SIMPLEST AND MOST COST EFFECTIVE
WAY. TO ENSURE LOW INCOME
SENIORS HAVE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HEALTH.
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY WOULD
ENSURE THAT THE VULNERABLE
POPULATION OF LOW INCOME SENIORS
ARE TREATED FAIRLY AND CAN HAVE
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE MEDICAL
CARE.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
LINDA WAY WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER FOR LAW AND POVERTY CLEAR
RAMSEY FROM JUSTICE IN AGING AND
ABROAD. NOW KURT TRIALS FROM
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. UNDER HEALTH REFORM
ADULTS LIKE WITH INCOMES UP TO A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT PERCENT
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LINE ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICAID HOW.
EXCEPT FOR SENIORS INDIVIDUALS
SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER ARE SUBJECT
TO A LOWER INCOME ELIGIBILITY
THRESHOLD OF A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE PERCENT OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LINE. A
DIFFERENCE OF ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DOLLARS A MONTH.
THAN TWELVE.
TWELVE ENGINE FORTY TWO DOLLARS
A MONTH HERE SHE CAN ONLY GET
MEDI CAL WITH THE SHARE OF COSTS
MEANING. THEY HAVE TO BUT I PAY.
I THEIR INCOME MINUS SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS HOT BEFORE MEDICARE HOW
KICKS AND A THIS IS BASED ON THE
ANTIQUATED IDEA THAT PEOPLE CAN
LIVE OFF OF SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
A MONTH. THIS MIGHT HAVE BEEN
TRUE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
WHEN THERE SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR
MITNICK STEVE INCOME LEVEL WAS
ESTABLISHED BASED CERTAINLY NOT
TRUE TODAY.
THAT THAT THE GRASS THAT THAT I
HAS BEEN SHARED WITH YOU WAS.
GRAPH RELEASED BY THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET. UP POLICY
CENTER JUST TODAY SHOWING THAT
END OF. WHAT A BAD BIRTH YEAR A
SIXTY FIVE CAN BE IT SHOWS THAT
AN INDIVIDUAL WITH AN INCOME OF
THIRTEEN FIFTY? AYE AT AGE SIXTY
FOUR IS ELIGIBLE FOR FREE MEDI
CAL BUT WHEN'S.
HERE SHE TURNED SIXTY FIVE NOW
HAS ITS SHARE OF COSTS OF OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
THAT'S OVER HALF THEIR INCOME
WHICH HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR
THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME MENEM'S
CLEAR RAMSEY I'M AN ATTORNEY
WITH JUSTICE IN AGING AND I
REALLY WANNA FOCUS ON TWO
ELEMENTS OF THIS BILL.
ONE IS THAT IT IS A VERY
EFFECTIVE METHOD MECHANISM TO
MITIGATE SENIOR POVERTY AND IT
WILL CREATE EQUITY BETWEEN
SENIORS AND OTHER ADULT MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES.
AS YOU'VE PROBABLY HEARD IN IN
OTHER BILLS THERE'S A GROWING
NUMBER OF SENIORS IN CALIFORNIA
LIVING IN POVERTY. AND ONE OF
THE MAIN DRIVERS UP THIS POVERTY
INCREASE IS HIGH MEDICAL COSTS.
FREE MEDI CAL IS IN ONE OF THE
MOST EFFECTIVE WAYS
TO CLEAR MEDICAL COSTS AND TO
KEEP THEM DOWN FOR SENIORS.
AND AS LINDA MENTIONED RIGHT NOW
WE'RE TALKING AT SENIORS WHO ARE
BETWEEN TWELVE HUNDRED FORTY TWO
DOLLARS AND THIRTEEN HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN DOLLARS A MONTH. SO
WE KNOW IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S
BARELY ENOUGH TO PAY FOR RENT
AND FOOD AND IF YOU ADD IN THE
HIGH MEDICAL COSTS PEOPLE ARE
MAKING DRACONIAN CHOICES BETWEEN
FOOD. RENT
MEDICINE GOING TO DOCTORS AND
PAYING COPAYS.
I JUST WANNA HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU
WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW AND
THERE'S THREE TIMELY EXAMPLES
THAT HAVE COME ON TO MY DESK
WITHIN THE LAST WEEK.
FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY FROM LA
COUNTY AND FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY.
WHERE SENIORS WHO RECEIVED A
COLA INCREASE FROM THE SOCIAL
SECURITY OF ABOUT TWENTY DOLLARS
A MONTH?
HAVE BASICALLY NOW STARTING
APRIL FIRST FLIPPED FROM FREE
MEDICAL WHERE THEY COULD ACCESS
THEIR IN HOME SUPPORT SERVICES
AND THEIR ADULT DAY HEALTH
PROGRAM AND ALL THE OTHER
MEDICAL.
ASSISTANTS ARE NOW IN SHARE
COST MEDI CAL. AND ALL OF THEM
WERE SITTING WITH THE SHOW OF
COST OF SOMEWHERE AROUND SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS A
MONTH.
SO IN MARCH THEY CAN AFFORD
THEIR HEALTHCARE AND IN APRIL
NOW THEY CAN'T.
AND IF AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY GET
YOUR VOTE AND HOUSES THIS IS THE
BILL THAT WILL BASICALLY ALLOW
THE SENIORS TO ACCESS ALL THE
BENEFITS THAT THEY REQUIRE TO
LIVE SAFELY IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND TO AVOID INSTITUTIONAL
PLACEMENTS.
SO THANK YOU WE URGE AYE VOTE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KURT CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO BE ABLE
TO CO SPONSOR THIS LEGISLATIN
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT.
I'VE BEEN OF ANOMALY THAT.
WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO CRACK
FOR.
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS THAT JUST
SEEMS TO GET A LITTLE WORSE
EVERY YEAR.
AND SO WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO BE
ABLE TO.
WORK AGAIN ON TRYING TO.
GET THIS FIXED WE'D WE DID
THINK IT WAS IMPORTANT TO GET
YOU.
THE GRAPH THAT OUR FRIENDS AT
THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER PUT OUT AND WHILE WE
ORDINARILY DON'T PRINT DOES IN
COLOR WE THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO SEE. SIXTY
FOUR ZERO SIXTY FIVE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS AND
SHARING COSTS AND THAT'S REALLY
WHAT THE THE BLUNT EDGE OF.
THE IMPACT IS THAT THIS BILL
FAXES LIKE YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IT'S YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JOHN FRAWLEY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH PLANS AND WORKS PART OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS HAVE TO BUST LOCAL
HEALTH PLANS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
NATASHA PHILLIPS CALIFORNIA
COVERAGE IN HEALTH INITIATIVES
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JACQUELINE AND IS FROM A A RP
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
TRUTH ANDERSON WITH ARKIN UCP
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION AND
SUPPORT KEPT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER BEHALF OF ALZHEIMER'S BUT
A LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT
THINKING.
ALISON REMY WITH BLUE SHIELD OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
KELLY BROKE SOME HAVE OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS
IN THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION ALL HERE IN SUPPORT.
MIKE MONTGOMERY WITH THE
CONGRESS OF CALIFORNIA SENIORS
WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
I CARE.
PARDON CARVAJAL WITH THE
HERNANDEZ STRATEGY GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE IN SPORT.
LISA COLEMAN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT.
TELEPHONE CAROL SO FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CHRISTOPHER GALIANO THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GEN HAMPTON WITH LEAVING IT
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT.
NO I BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK
WINDOWS WITH S. YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CAN REALLY CHAO THE CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK IN A
HAVING YOUR SAY COAST COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
ANGELA DRUG NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
FOR SOCIAL WORKERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MARY VALDEZ OF HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
FRED MAIN CAL PACE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
AND WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
AS ARIANNA SEKHEMRE MISS WALDRON
MISSED DOCTOR ARAMBULA WHICH I
THINK.
IF I CAN'T I JUST WANTED TO
THANK SOMEONE IT'S IT'S FUNNY
HOW WE GET THESE IDEAS FOR
BILLS.
THIS ONE HAPPENED AT.
.
KITCHEN TABLE ABOUT A YEAR AGO
MY MOTHER ACTUALLY FOUND THIS
ONE AND RECOMMENDED IT. SHE'S A
LEGAL AID LAWYER AND.
HAD A CLIENT WHO CAME AND WHO.
ONE YEAR WAS ABLE TO MAKE ENDS
MEET AND THE NEXT YEAR WHEN SHE
TURNED SIXTY FIVE COULD NOT.
AND IT WAS THIS COST OF SHEER
CLIFF THAT YOU'VE HEARD
PRESENTED HERE TODAY.
SO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
CONSIDERING THE SPELL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE.
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANKS TO THANKS TO
MOM.
.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE GROWTH OF THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAIENSCHEIN AYE ANCHOR CURRY?
BAKER CURRY AYE BONTA. BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA AYE LOW
MOAN.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN. THIS ARYAN AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH THURMAN. THURMAN AYE
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE.
FIXER.
TWELVE.
THAT'S TWELVE ZERO SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
MISTER BLOOM.
MISTER BLOOM WILL BE PRESENTING
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY FOUR.
S..
AND MEMBERS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY FOUR WHICH WOULD
ENSHRINE THE HEALTH.
HEALTH IN ALL POLICIES TASK
FORCE INTO A PERMANENT PROGRAM.
THE HEALTH AND ALL POLICIES OR.
OF THIS GREAT ACRONYM.
HI ATOP. OF TASK FORCE WELL IT
REALLY.
SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING YOU SAY WE
GET UP ON A HORSE.
HI AT.
TO DO THAT ONE BUT.
THIS TASK FORCE WITH THIS
TABLET'S BY EXECUTIVE ORDER AND
TWENTY TEN BY THEN GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER.
THE GIVE YEAH BUT I CAN.
IT'S THE THIS TASK FORCE WAS THE
FIRST OF ITS KIND IN THE NATION
AND BRINGS TOGETHER EIGHTEEN
STATE AGENCIES DEPARTMENTS AND
OFFICES TO IDENTIFY PRIORITY
PROGRAMS POLICIES AND STRATEGIES
TO IMPROVE. THE HEALTH OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS SOMETHING I THINK
WE CAN ALL AGREE IS IMPORTANT.
THE HIGH UP TASK FORCE PLAYS A
CRITICAL ROLE IN CONNECTING
AGENCIES OF PROMOTING HEALTH
CONSIDERATIONS DECISION MAKING
WITHIN AGENCIES. ADDED ALSO
PLAYS AN IMPORTANT PART
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO AGENCIES.
BECAUSE OF THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE HIGH APRS ACTUALLY
HELPED CREATE PROGRAMS SUCH AS
THE OFFICE OF FARM TO FORK.
PROGRAMS THAT TO INCREASE
HEALTHY TREES AND SCHOOLS THAT
PROVIDE NATURAL CANOPY AND HEAT
RELIEF ARE IN THOSE SCHOOLS AND
HYPE IS HELPED DEVELOP HEALTH
INEQUITY TOOLS AND STATE.
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING AS WELL.
THE TASK FORCE HAS A PROVEN
TRACK RECORD FOR PROMOTING A
HEALTHIER CALIFORNIA IN AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY FOUR INSURERS
THAT IT'LL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
ITS GOOD WORK. ON A PERMANENT
BASIS WITH ME I HAVE KIM CHEN
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK SPONSORED THE
BILL AND JUDI ROBINSON FROM.
AT THE.
DESIGNED FOR ACTIVE
SACRAMENTO.
PARTICULARLY TENANTS THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH OR
PROUD O SPONSOR AND SUPPORT AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY FOUR STEVEN
HAS BEEN A KEY STAKEHOLDER IN
SUPPORT OF HIGH UP SINCE ITS
INCEPTION. TO THE GREAT WORK
THEY DO TODAY AND WE'RE PLEASED
TO SEE THIS WAR CONTINUE WITH.
THIS BILL WE KNOW THAT ON ITS
OWN ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE IS NOT
ONLY ONE PART OF WHAT KEEPS US
HEALTHY IN THEIR MANY OTHER
FACTORS THAT CAN SUPPORT A BLOCK
A PERSON'S ABILITY TO LEAD A
HEALTHY LIFE.
FROM WHETHER FAMILIES HAVE
ACCESS TO
FOODS TO.
QUALITY OF THE AIR THAT.
PEOPLE BREATHE IN THESE FACTORS
ARE BROADLY UNDERSTOOD AS SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
DECISIONS BY POLICY MAKERS AND
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS INCLUDE
CONSIDERATIONS FOR SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS CAN HAVE A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON HEALTH
OUTCOMES.
AND THE HEALTH AND ALL POLICIES
TASK FORCES THE APPROACH THAT
SYSTEMATICALLY TAKES THIS INTO
ACCOUNT AND AS MISTER BLOOM A
SPOKE TO THE STATE TOOK A
LEADERSHIP ROLE EIGHT YEARS AGO
IS IN ESTABLISHING THE HIGH
PASSPORTS.
AND WITH THIS BILL WILL MAKE
SURE THAT THIS WORK CONTINUES IN
A PERMANENT MANNER POPPED INTO A
PROGRAM
WE ARE SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON HONORABLE TWENTY
MEMBERS. THANK YOU YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU IN
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION TO
KEEP HEALTH AND ALL STATE
POLICIES.
MY NAME IS JUDY ROBINSON ON A
PRINCIPLE PLANNER CHAIR OF
DESIGN TRACTOR
SACRAMENTO PART OF THE NONPROFIT
WALK SACRAMENTO. ACROSS SECTOR
HEALTH AND BUILT ENVIRONMENT
TEAM WHO'S BEEN WORKING ACROSS
THE REGION STATE AND NATION.
TO EMBED HEALTH AND POLICIES
PRACTICES AND PROJECTS MY
COMMENTS TODAY ARE BASED ON
EXPERIENCES WITH DESIGN FRACTOR
SACRAMENTO AND THE EXPERTISE
WE'VE DEVELOPED THAT ADVANCING
IMPLEMENT HEALTH AND ALL
POLICIES.
OUR WORK STARTED BECAUSE HIGH UP
AND IS TO SEE INCLUDED HEALTH
QUESTIONS IN THIS EARLY
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES AND
URBAN GRINNING GRANT PROGRAMS.
BY ANSWERING THESE QUESTIONS WE
LEARNED THAT THE WAY THAT WE'VE
BEEN BUILDING ARE COMMUNITIES
HAS EXACERBATED CHRONIC DISEASE.
AND SOCIAL ISOLATION MAKING IT
HARDER FOR PEOPLE LIVE HEALTHY
AND PRODUCTIVE LIVES.
WHAT RESULTED WAS A CREATION OF
DESIGN TRACTOR SACRAMENTO
COMPRISED OF PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS TRANSPORTATION
ENGINEERS LAND USE PLANNERS?
WHAT SACRAMENTO IN PRIVATE
SECTOR PHYSICIANS INCLUDING IN
NEUROSURGEON?
DESIGNED FOR AFTER SACRAMENTO
WORK WAS SACRAMENTO COUNTY TO
ADOPT HEALTH POLICIES IN THEIR
GENERAL PLAN AND ADDRESS HEALTH
THROUGH ACTIVE DESIGN.
AFTER DESIGN AND HEALTH WAS
ADOPTED INTO THE COUNTY ZONING
CODE AND COUNTY WIDE DESIGN
GUIDELINES FIRST IN THE COUNTRY
TO CODIFY. HEALTH INTO A
DEVELOPMENT CODE.
IN THE COURSE OF DOING THIS WORK
WE ENGAGED WITH STATE HEALTH AND
ALL POLICY STAFF TO UNDERSTAND
HOW WE COULD SUPPORT EACH OTHER
IN THE WORK. AND WHAT HEALTH
LOOKS LIKE IN THE GROUND.
WE'VE WORKED TOGETHER WITH STATE
HIGH UP STAFF FOR YEARS FINDING
WAYS OF STATE POLICY CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IN COMMUNITIES AND NEIGHBORHOODS
WHERE HEALTH HAPPENS.
IN SPREADING HIGH AB GOALS WE'VE
BEEN BRINGING TOGETHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HEALTH TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING ANOTHER SECTORS SHOWING
THEM WITH THEIR WORK INTERSEX
AND HOW THEY CAN INFLUENCE
POSITIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES BY
CONSIDERING HEALTH. IN THEIR
POLICIES PRACTICES AND PROJECTS
WE SUPPORTED HIGH UP STAFF IN
EXPANDING HEALTH QUESTIONS INTO
GRANT APPLICATIONS AND IN
PARTICULAR EXTRA POINTS.
AWARD OF THE CALTRANS ACTED
TRANSPORTATION SCORING RUBRICS
FOR ENGAGING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS.
WHEN COMPLETE IN THE GRANT
APPLICATION THIS IS CRITICAL
BECAUSE ENGINEERS AND PLANNERS
WHO ARE WRITING THE GRANTS HAVE
LIMITED KNOWLEDGE OF HOW
COMMUNITY DESIGN AND HEALTH ARE
LINKED.
THERE AND AWARE OF ALL THIS
HEALTH DATA THAT'S AVAILABLE AND
THEY'RE NOT IN COMMUNICATION
WITH THEIR HEALTH COLLEAGUES.
THAT CAN HELP THEM CONNECT THE
HEALTH DOTS.
THE SCOOP S SCORING RUBRICS ARE
DRIVING EDUCATION AND CHANGE AND
THE BEAUTY OF INVENTING HEALTH
AND ALL POLICIES. AND HOW WE
BUILD OUR COMMUNITIES IS OF THE
HIGHER UP APPROACH IS EQUITABLE
PROVIDES FOR QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
ALL. AND HELPS COMMUNITIES BE
RESILIENT IN OUR CHANGING
CLIMATE.
STATE HIGH UP IS MAKING POSITIVE
IMPACTS ACROSS THE STATE AND THE
LOCAL LEVEL AS IT WAS INTENDED.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON COOLER KOENIG
WILL BE UP THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION AMERICAN STROKE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
YOU VERY MUCH.
CARE MEMBERS CUT THE MUSTARD
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE STRONG
SUPPORT.
MARY ABOUT OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT IF YOU.
KELLY BROOK SO THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION ALSO HERE
IN SUPPORT.
NO I BOTTOM OR WITH CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION NON BEHALF OF THE
HAVING OUR SAY COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
I THINK ABOUT HOW WITH COMMITTEE
HEALTH COUNCILS IN LOS ANGELES
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
THURMAN THINK WE COULD LASSO
AROUND UP OF SECOND SECOND
CHOQUET MR MCCARTY.
ALRIGHT SO WE WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER THURMAN THE SECOND BY
MR MCCARTY. MOTION IS THE DO
PASSED TO.
RESOURCES.
OKAY. OFF WE GO.
THE.
METACENTRIC PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WHAT I'VE WHEN AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE AYE CARE CURRY
AYE CAREFREE AYE? BONTA.
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
FLORA.
OR I AM LIMON.
THE MOON I MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN AYE MISSOURI AYE
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WALDRON.
IT.
INVEST TEN VOTES THE BILL'S OUT
AND I WOULD SAY THAT'S THE FIRST
THAT I HAVE WE HAVE DOUBLE HAS
SEEN I'VE SEEN A DOUBLE REFERRED
BUILT FROM HEALTH AND NATURAL
RESOURCES SO.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR BLOOD.
THANK YOU.
SEEN LOOKING FOR MISS RUBIO I
DON'T SEE OFICINAS I'M SORRY.
I SEE YOU NOW WHICH YOU'RE
WAVING NASA.
COME ON UP MISS RUBIO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY SIX.
VERY SUBTLE.
I THINK MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
TODAY AND PRESENTING AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN SIX THAT WOULD
EXTEND.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AUTHORITY TO
ENFORCE FEDERAL FACILITY
STANDARDS FOR SPECIFIED LICENSE
CLINICS WHICH IS A CHRONIC AYE
DIALYSIS SURGICAL AND
REHABILITATION AND CERTAIN
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY ARE I'M
SORRY DISABLED NURSING
FACILITIES. THE DEPARTMENT'S
CURRENT AUTHORITY LAPSED TIME
DURING THAT GENERATE FIRST OF
THIS YEAR. AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY SIX SIX EXTEND THE
AUTHORITY UNTIL JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE REQUIRING
THOSE FACILITIES TO COMPLY WITH
SPECIFIED FEDERAL CERTIFICATION
STANDARDS. UNTIL REGULATIONS ARE
ADOPTED BY THE DEPARTMENT.
THE REINSTATEMENT OF THE ABILITY
FOR THE STATE TO ENFORCE FEDERAL
STANDARDS PROVIDE A FLOOR IN A
BEEF TWENTY FOUR SEVEN SIX WILL
ENSURE. THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH CAN ENFORCE BASIC
STANDARDS OF CARE PROVIDED IN
THESE CLINICS AND REHABILITATION
NURSING FACILITIESFOR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS MOST
OF VULNERABLE RESIDENTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR THIS MUCH NEEDED
PROPOSAL WITH ME TODAY I HAVE A
CRISPY FOR FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DIALYSIS COUNCIL.
WELL WE'VE GOT SOME EXUBERANT
PEOPLE HAVE SUFFERED NO MA'AM
PLEASE GOD A HOME ON THE LAST
ONE HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHRISTY
FLOYD HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DIALYSIS COUNCIL
WHICH IS A STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION
OF. DIALYSIS CLINICS KNOWN AS IN
STAGE RENAL DISEASE FACILITIES.
AND IN TWENTY THIRTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH SPONSORED S. . FIVE
THIRTY FOUR THAT BILL REQUIRED
THESE TYPES OF CLINICS TO COMPLY
WITH THE FACILITY SPECIFIC
FEDERAL CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS. TO MEET THE STATE
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS
INTEL THE DEPARTMENT ADOPT STATE
REGULATIONS THAT AUTHORITY
ENACTED IN S. B. FIVE THIRTY
FIVE BY THIRTY FORMS ARE EXPIRED
JANUARY FIRST OF THIS YEAR.
SO THE REINSTATEMENT PROVIDER
FOREIGN AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
SIX WILL ENSURE THAT THE STATE
CAN ENFORCE. THE FEDERAL STANCES
STANDARDS OF CARE PROVIDED FOR
IN THESE CLINICS
FOR THESE REASONS ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF OUR BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NO ONE WILL BRING PATSY.
ANYONE OPPOSITION EXCUSE ME.
IT YOU KNOW AND BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SO WE HAD A MOTION FROM MISS
WORK WITH ACOSTA TIE WOULD MISS
ME TAKE YOUR CURRY WILL GIVE
CREDIT FOR THIS MONTH. SECOND BY
MISTER THURMAN.
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE THIS REVIEW.
THIS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE PERFECTLY. SO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WOULD I
WOULD I MAIENSCHEIN. MAINTAIN
AYE ACTOR CURRY.
I HEAR CURRY AYE BONTA.
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA. FLORA AYE
LIMON.
THE MOMENT I MCCARTY. MCCARTY
AYE NAZARIAN.
THE SYRIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH.
BERMAN. BERMAN I'VE WALDRON.
IT'S ELEVEN ZERO YOUR BILL WAS I
THINK A MEASURE WHICH RUBIO.
THIS POINT WILL GO TO MISTER HIS
AREA.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS WHICH.
ENSURE THAT QUALIFIED
DISTRIBUTIONS WOULD NOT BE
COUNTED AS INCOME.
I HAVE ALSO PROPOSED FINDINGS
AND DECORATIONS WHICH REINFORCED
THE IMPORTANCE OF SAVING FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION. A AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE WOULD EXCLUDE THE
PRINCIPAL AND INTEREST OF A FIVE
TWENTY NINE COLLEGE SAVINGS
PLAN.
FOR AN ASSET OR A RESOURCES TEST
TO DETERMINE MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY FOR NON MANAGE AYE
POPULATION.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THIS GROUP
WHICH GENERALLY CONSISTS OF LOW
INCOME SENIORS THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES AND THOSE AND LONG
TERM CARE. REMAIN SUBJECT TO
PROPERTY AND INCOME TESTS
IN ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR MEDICAL
SERVICES.
IT'S A GREAT BILL I LIKE IT I
HOPE YOU ALL LIKE IT. AND WITH
ME AS JAN FLOREY FROM THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY.
AND SABRINA HAM FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSET BUILDING
COALITION.
JEFF ARE YOU SIR GEN FLORA THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY.
WHERE THE OLDEST AND LARGEST
LEGAL SERVICES SUPPORT CENTER IN
THE STATE AND OUR HEALTH TEAM
FOCUSES PRIMARILY ON MEDI CAL WE
ALSO WORK WITH THE HEALTH
CONSUMER ALLIANCES SERVES ALL OF
THAT CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
CONSUMERS?
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT CALIFORNIA SPLIT ITS
POPULATION IT TO TO INCOME
COUNTING METHODOLOGIES THE FIRST
ONE THE MODIFIED ADJUSTED GROSS
INCOME.
METHODOLOGY IS BASED ON
ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME WHICH
COMES FROM TAX FILINGS.
SO FOR THAT METHODOLOGY THAT
APPLIES TO PARENTS CHILDREN AND
THE EXPANSION ADULTS WHICH WERE
ADULTS THAT FORMERLY HAD NO
LINKAGE TO THE MEDICARE PROGRAM.
THE ADDITIONAL POPULATION WHICH
IS THE SAME POPULATION WE JUST
SPOKE ABOUT WITH AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY. IS NON MATCH I.
THOSE ARE ADULTS OVER AGE SIXTY
FIVE PEOPLE IN LINKED PROGRAMS
SOME PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
WHO ARE INELIGIBLE FOR THE ADULT
EXPANSION GROUP BECAUSE THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE.
AS WELL AS CERTAIN OTHER
SPECIAL POPULATIONS.
SO WHETHER A FIVE TWENTY NINE
PLANET CAN'T PLAN COUNTS AGAINST
US A MEDICO APPLICANT DEPENDS ON
WHETHER YOU'RE IN MATCH I MEDI
CAL OR NON.
ACCOUNT.
IN MATCH I MEDI CAL WE DON'T
HAVE IN ASSETS TEST ANYMORE IN
NON MATCH I MEDI CAL WE DO SO
CURRENTLY IT'S YOU KNOW
QUESTIONABLE WHETHER IT THAT
FIVE TWENTY NINE PLAN WOULD
COUNT AGAINST YOU.
AND THEN WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE PROPOSED INCOME SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE QUALIFY
DISTRIBUTIONS WHEN YOU GO TO USE
YOUR FIVE TWENTY NINE PLAN TO
ACCESS EDUCATION.
IF YOU'RE IN MATCH I MEDI CAL.
THIS IS NOT TAXABLE INCOME SO IT
DOESN'T COUNT AGAINST YOU IF
YOU'RE NOT MATCH I MEDI CAL
AGAIN IT CAN COUNT AGAINST YOU
AS INCOME.
SO AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FIVE IS
REALLY JUST ENSURING THAT ALL
MEDI CAL RECIPIENTS CAN USE FIVE
TWENTY NINE. PLANS TO THE SAME
EXTENT MEDI CAL RECIPIENTS
SHOULD NOT BE DISCOURAGED FROM
SAVING FROM PLANNING FOR THE
FUTURE OR FROM USING A DEDICATED
EDUCATIONAL FUND. FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXPENSES
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THE HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
CLEARLY IN ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT THERE
WERE SOME IN INTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. AND WE THINK THIS
IS A GOOD START TO START LOOKING
AT THE ASSETS AGAIN.
STARTING WITH A TAX ADVANTAGE
PLAN THAT ON ONE HAND THE
GOVERNMENT IS ENCOURAGING AND
THE ON THE OTHER HAND IS
PENALIZING SOME PEOPLE FROM
ACCESSING THEIR HEALTHCARE
BENEFITS.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU I
CHAIRPERSON AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY MY NAME
IS SABRINA HAMMER I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSET BUILDING
COALITION. WE ARE. A LOW WE
REPRESENT OVER TWO HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE COMMITTED TO HELPING
LOW INCOME FAMILIES BECOME MORE
FINANCIALLY STABLE.
AND WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
WE RECOGNIZE THAT PUBLIC
BENEFITS AND ABILITY TO SAVE
SHOULD WORK IN TANDEM TO SUPPORT
ECONOMIC MOBILITY. AND FINANCIAL
SECURITY FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS.
CURLY UNDERSTANDS BY DENYING
ACCOUNTS ARE CONSIDERED FOR MEDI
CAL ELIGIBILITY FOR NON MATCH I.
THIS LEAVES LOW INCOME FAMILIES
IN A TOUGH SPOT THEY MUST CHOOSE
BETWEEN SAVING FOR COLLEGE AND
STAYING ELIGIBLE FOR AFFORDABLE
HEALTH CARE.
IT'S APPARENT THAT ASSET LIMITS
PRESENTS A SERIOUS BARRIER.
TO SAVINGS FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES WHO RELY ON PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE.
CALIFORNIA DEMONSTRATED THEIR
COMMITMENT TO SUPPORTING
FAMILIES TO SAVE FOR COLLEGE OR
THE INTRODUCED SCHOLAR SHARE A
STATE RUN FIVE TWENTY NINE
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNT MANY
DECADES AGO.
SINCE THEN SCHOLARSHIP HAS
WORKED TO HELP OVER. TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS OPEN SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE COLLEGE SAVINGS
CAPS.
JUST THIS YEAR SCOTT WILSHIRE
INTRODUCED A.
A MATCHING GRANT PROGRAM FOR
FAMILIES EARNING LESS THAN
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR.
THIS PROGRAM WILL MATCH SAVINGS
CONTRIBUTIONS FOR UP TO TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS.
WHICH MAY NOT SEEM LIKE A LOT
BEFORE LOW INCOME FAMILIES THIS
IS A. HUGE STEP FOR THEM.
CB SI IS A PROUD PARTNER OF
SCHOLARSHIP BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT LOW INCOME
FAMILIES NEED ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
AND SAVING FOR THE FUTURE.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT STUDENTS WITH
AT LEAST FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
COLLEGE SAVINGS IS THREE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO ENROLL HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND FOUR TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO GRADUATE THAN THOSE
WITHOUT A COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNT.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FIVE AS A
NECESSARY STEP IN REMOVING
BEARS.
TO COLLEGE SAVINGS FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS WHO
OPEN UP TWENTY FIVE TWENTY NINE.
SAVING ACCOUNTS FOR THEIR
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN ALSO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE AND
COLLEGE SAVINGS AND THEY SHOULD
NOT BE PIN PENALIZED. FOR
HELPING THEIR LOVED ONES AFFORD.
THE COST OF HIGHER EDUCATION
FURTHER RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
THE COST OF ATTENDING HIGHER
EDUCATION IS A HUGE FACTOR
RETENTION RATES AMONG LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
WE MUST REMOVE BARRIERS THAT
KEEP LOW INCOME FAMILIES FROM
SAVING FOR THE FUTURE STATE TO
KATHY CLOCK EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
FOR AN ECONOMIC MOBILITY AND THE
CHANCE TO FOR THE COST OF
ATTENDING COLLEGE.
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DESIGN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR TYPE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS TO
SUPPORT.
OH WEST SAM'S IF UNITED WAYS OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
NO I BOTTOM WITH CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
KELLY PARTS OF THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
THE ONE IN OPPOSITION.
NO ONE WILL BRING IT BACK TO.
MOTIONS.
DO NOT HAVE A MUCH SOME OF WE DO
NOW.
.
WHAT THE SECOND WAS?
THE TIGER THE MOTION.
FRED MATHIS REYES RODRIGUEZ SO.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANYONE.
SAID MISTER YET IS THAT WE'VE
HAD A LOT OF DEBATE ABOUT FIVE
TWENTY NINE ACCOUNTS NEVER IN
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE. NORMALLY
IN THE HIGHER ADDER. AND
TAXATION BUT.
WE NEED TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
SAVE IN GENERAL AND SAVE FOR
COLLEGE IS IS SO KEY INTO. WE
DON'T WANT TO HURT PEOPLE'S ON.
MEDICAL OPPORTUNITIES IN MEDICAL
COVERAGE BY MAKING FOR HAVING
THEM INVEST IN THEIR IN THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS COLLEGE. PLANNED
SO THIS IS A SMART EFFORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
SEEING NO ONE WILL.
.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
MCCARTY A SECOND BY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WOULD I WOULD I MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAIENSCHEIN AYE AYE HERE CURRY
BAKER CURRY AYE BONTA. PUTS AYE
BURKE BURKE I CARILLO CREEL I
FLORA. FLORA AND AMONG.
MON AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN.
I NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO AYE AYE
SANTIAGO AYE. STEINORTH.
CURRENT THURMOND AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
IT'S FOURTEEN ZERO VICKI VERY
MUCH MISS USER HERE BILLS ON ITS
WAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MR MAIENSCHEIN.
PRESENTING THE FINAL TO LOOK THE
DAY.
AB TWO ZERO ONE A.
THANK YOU I.
I RECOGNIZE THE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF BEFORE I BEGIN I'LL
BE ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS
DESCRIBED IN THE ANALYSIS TO
ALLOW ALL CURRENT HEALTHCARE
PRACTITIONERS ELIGIBLE. FOR THE
STEVEN M. THOMPSON POSITION
CORPS LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM TO
APPLY FOR EARLY LOAN REPAYMENTS
INSTEAD OF PROVIDING EARLY
LONGER PAYMENTS ONLY.
TO PSYCHIATRIC TRAINEES.
THE SHORTAGE OF PSYCHIATRISTS IN
THE UNITED STATES HAS REACHED
CRISIS LEVELS AND CALIFORNIA
SUFFERING THE FALLOUT. THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL FOR BEHOLD
BEHAVE ORIEL HEALTH IN ITS
TWENTY SEVENTEEN REPORT
PROJECTED THE DEMAND FOR
PSYCHIATRY WHICH OUTSTRIP
SERVICES BY TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. AS IT NOW
STANDS FIFTY FIVE PERCENT OF
COUNTIES IN THE U. S. HAVE NO
PSYCHIATRISTS AND SEVENTY SEVEN
PERCENT HAVE A SEVERE SHORTAGE.
THE SHORTAGES CREATED CRITICAL
WEAKNESSES IN OUR PUBLIC MENTAL
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT
COUNTIES ARE STRUGGLING TO PATCH
BY EXPANDING THE ROLES OF OTHER
CATEGORIES OF WORKERS. SUCH AS
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND PEER PROVIDERS
HOWEVER A LASTING SOLUTION
REQUIRES A MORE SUBSTANTIVE FIX
THAT REVITALIZES THE FIELD. AND
MUST INCLUDE A POWERFUL
INCENTIVE TO STEER PROMISING
STUDENTS INTO CAREERS AND
COMMUNITY PSYCHIATRY ENSURING
OUR MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO QUALITY
PSYCHIATRIC CARE.
AB TWENTY EIGHTEEN ADDRESSES THE
SHORTAGE BY TACKLING THE HEAVY
BURDEN OF DEBT SO MANY STUDENTS
SHOULDER AS A PURSUE AN ADVANCED
MEDICAL DEGREE. IT IS NOT
UNUSUAL IN CALIFORNIA TO FIND
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENTS IN
TRAINING WITH DEBT LOADS THAT
EXCEED TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
FOR DECADES GOVERNMENTS HAVE
USED LOAN REPAYMENT AND LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAMS TO FUEL
INTEREST IN HARD TO FILL
PRACTICE SECTORS DEEMED VITAL TO
THE PUBLIC INTEREST. AB TWENTY
EIGHTEEN MORE EXPANSIVE PROGRAMS
FOR PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO COMMIT TO WORKING
IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
AB TWENTY EIGHTEEN OUR DOCTOR
PRETTY A FELLOW WHEN YOU SEE ES
DE PROGRAM AND DOCTOR CUNNINGHAM
A RECENT GRADUATE OF YOU SEE.
CISCO PROGRAM ADRIN SHELTON WITH
THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE AND
RANDALL HAGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC ASSESS
ASSOCIATION ARE ALSO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THE PRE SCRATCH.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY.
MY NAME SPREE THE OSHA I AM A
FELLOW AT UC SAN DIEGO'S
COMMUNITY PSYCHIATRY PROGRAM AND
I'LL BE GRADUATING THIS JUNE. I
HAVE HAD THE UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
TO ROTATE AT A NUMBER OF SITES
OUTSIDE OF THE TRADITIONAL
ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTER ALL OVER
SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
SOME OF THOSE INCLUDE THE
SURVIVORS OF TORTURE
INTERNATIONAL WHICH IS A PROGRAM
THAT TAKES CARE OF FOLKS WHO ARE
HERE SEEKING ASYLUM AFTER HAVING
BEEN TORTURED IN THEIR HOME
COUNTRIES. I ALSO WORK WITH SAN
DIEGO YOU'D SERVICES WHICH IS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT SUPPORTS WOMEN
BETWEEN THE AGES OF TWELVE AND
TWENTY FOUR WHO ARE SURVIVORS OF
SEX TRAFFICKING.
I AM THE PSYCHIATRIST TO THE
DEAF COMMUNITY SERVICES OF SAN
DIEGO AS WELL AS ONE OF THE
DOCKS AT ARE COUNTIES URGENT
MENTAL HEALTH WALK IN CLINIC.
THE FIFTH SITE THAT A ROTATE
OUT.
THIS YEAR IS A FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTER JUST
NORTH OF THE MEXICAN BORDER
WHERE I WORK WITH PREDOMINANTLY
A HISPANIC POPULATION.
SO WITH THIS OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH SO MANY DIFFERENT GROUPS OF
PEOPLE I HAVE A VERY CLEAR IDEA
OF THE DAY DEFICIT THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH STATEWIDE IN TERMS
OF HOW HARD IT IS TO GET IN TO
SEE A PSYCHIATRIST.
THE WAIT TIME TO SEE ME AS AT
LEAST ONE TO TWO MONTHS AT MOST
OF THESE CLINICAL SITES AND
OFTENTIMES. EVEN MORE THAN I.
AB A STUDY THAT JUST CAME OUT OF
YOU SEE A STUFF A FEW MONTHS AGO
SUGGEST THAT OF THOSE
PSYCHIATRISTS THAT ARE
PRACTICING IN CALIFORNIA ONLY
FORTY SIX PERCENT SEE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE MEDI CAL COVERAGE. AND AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE FROM THE SITES
THAT I SHARED WITH YOU MOST OF
THE PATIENTS THAT I SEE. HAVE
MEDI CAL OR OR ARE UNFUNDED.
AND THE PROBLEMS ONLY GOING TO
GET WORSE.
THAT SEEMS STUDIES SUGGEST THAT
IN TEN YEARS WE WILL HAVE A
FORTY TO FIFTY PERCENT OF THE
STATE AND THE PSYCHIATRIST THAT
WE NEED.
SO THEN THE CONUNDRUM THAT THAT
I AND MANY OTHER RESIDENTS FACE
IS WHAT DO WE DO WHEN IT COMES
TIME TO FINDING OUR FIRST REAL
JOB. ALL GRADUATE THIS JUNE WITH
A COMMITMENT TO CONTINUING TO
SERVE THE COMMUNITY POPULATION
WHICH I HAVE. SO MUCH ENJOYED
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS
THE REALITY IS THOUGH THAT WHEN
I GRADUATE I WILL ALSO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT LOAN BURDEN.
ACCORDING TO BE A. M. C. THERE
IS THAT AN AVERAGE MEDICAL
STUDENT GRADUATION FEE OF TWO OF
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
OFTENTIMES IT'S EVEN HIGHER THAN
THAT.
SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE.
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS OF THE
NEED THAT WE KNOW WE NEED TO GET
FOLKS TO GO INTO COMMUNITY
PSYCHIATRY. BUT WE STILL NEED TO
CONSIDER WHAT'S HOLDING THEM
BACK.
BY PROMOTING SOME TYPE OF
LEGISLATION THAT WILL EXPAND THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR LOAN REPAYMENT
WE HAVE THE POTENTIAL FOR
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
RESIDENTS WHO LIKE ME WANT TO
SERVE IN THIS COMMUNITY BUT CAN
DO SO WITH A BIT MORE PEACE OF
MIND. SO STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION SO WE
CAN CONTINUE TO GIVE HIGH
QUALITY PSYCHIATRIC CARE TO THE
PATIENTS WHO DESERVE.
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US MY NAME
IS CARRIE CUNNINGHAM AND I AM AN
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR OF
PSYCHIATRY AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO.
IMPORTANT FAMILY AND COMMUNITY
MEDICINE AND PSYCHIATRY WHICH
MEANS THAT I HAVE HAD SEVEN
YEARS OF TRAINING AFTER MEDICAL
SCHOOL ALL THE WHILE ACCRUING
STUDENT LOAN INTEREST.
AM I SPEAKING STAYS A RECENT
GRADUATE OF THE UCSF PUBLIC
PSYCHIATRY FELLOWSHIP. I'LL ALSO
BE THE INCOMING MEDICAL DIRECTOR
AND A COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
CENTER. WORK AND MISSION IS TO
SUPPORT THE RECOVERY OF SAN
FRANCISCO'S HIGHEST REST
MENTALLY ILL ADULTS.
I'LL BE STARTING THIS POSITION
ONLY ONE OUT OF TRAINING WHICH I
BELIEVE IS A DIRECT RESULT OF
THEIR TREE TRAINING I RECEIVED
AS A PUBLIC PSYCHIATRY FOLLOW.
IN FACT THE DIRECTOR OF OUR
CLINIC IS ALSO A GRADUATE OF THE
SAME PUBLIC PSYCHIATRY
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM.
DO THE FELLOWSHIP I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN FROM
LEADERS IN THE BAY AREA AND
PUBLIC PSYCHIATRY AND LEARN
SKILLS TO HAVE PREPARED ME FOR
MY NEW ROLE. AS TO MY FELLOWSHIP
YEARS A COMMUNITY PSYCHIATRISTS
AND EMBEDDED PRIMARY CARE
CLINIC.
DURING MY FELLOWSHIP AND IN MY
CURRENT POSITION I WORK
PRIMARILY WITH PEOPLE WITH
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS MEANING
DIAGNOSES OF SCHIZOPHRENIA
BIPOLAR DISORDER AND AND OTHER
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESSES IN
ADDITION OF SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS.
PEOPLE OFTEN HAVE HISTORIES OF
INCARCERATION AND HIGH
UTILIZATION OF HEALTH CARE
SYSTEMS.
THIS WOULD LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM IS CRUCIAL IN ALLOWING
RESIDENTS TO CONTINUE TRAINING
IN PUBLIC PSYCHIATRY AND SUPPORT
FOLLOWS IN CHOOSING TO WORK IN
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEMS.
I KNOW ALL TOO WELL THAT
PURSUING THIS TRAINING ALSO
OFTEN MEANS OCCURRING GREATER
STUDENT LOAN THAT.
BUT APPARENTLY THIS TRAINING
PREPARES US TO WORK WITH SOME OF
THE MOST COMPLEX AND VULNERABLE
PATIENTS IN OUR SYSTEM.
ONE OF THE MANY STORIES
ILLUSTRATE THE VALUE PUBLIC
PSYCHIATRY THAT I CAN THINK OF
IS A YOUNG WOMAN I WORKED WITH
THIS YEAR WHO HAS A DIAGNOSIS OF
SCHIZOPHRENIA AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER.
SHE IS LIVING ENTITLED CAN'T
MEANT SLEEPING ONLY ON A
MATTRESS OUTSIDE AND WAS
FREQUENTLY HOSPITALIZED
THE ISSUE IS WELL KNOWN TO
PROVIDERS OUR SYSTEM SHE OFTEN
DECLINE TREATMENT.
UTILIZING THE KNOWLEDGE OF
SKILLS ARE DEVELOPED AS A PUBLIC
PSYCHIATRY FELLOW OUR TEAM WORKS
I WITH HER TOWARDS SCHOOLS OF
HOUSING SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT.
AND COORDINATION WITH COMMUNITY
SERVICES.
CLINICALLY I ALSO LEARNED TO
MEET PATIENTS WHERE THEY'RE AT
WHICH MAN AT ONE POINT KNOCKING
ON THREE DIFFERENT WHITE VANS IN
THE TUNDRA LINE TO TRY TO FIND
HER TARA REACHED HER.
SHE'S NOW SAFELY HOUSED
REGULARLY ATTENDING MENTAL
HEALTH AND PRIMARY CARE VISITS
AND ABOUT TO START EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM.
I'VE ALREADY WITNESSED THE
POSITIVE IMPACT OF MY PUBLIC
SICK PSYCHIATRY FELLOWSHIP
TRAINING AND URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS.
I DON'T THINK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
STERN NAME AND ORGANIZATION
PLEASE HI DR STEVE CO
PSYCHIATRISTS OUT DIRECTOR FOR
COMMITTEES A CULTURE PROGRAM AT
UC SAN DIEGO STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HELLO DOCTOR CRISTINA MAIN
GURION I'M DIRECTOR OF THE UCSF
PUBLIC PSYCHIATRY FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM IN STRONG SUPPORT THINK.
I AM DOCTOR STEPHANIE MARTINEZ A
SECOND YEAR PSYCHIATRY RESIDENT
AT UCSD IN THE COMMUTER TRACK I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS TIFFANY CASTILLO I
AM A FIRST YEAR PSYCHIATRY
RESIDENT IN THE COMMUNITY TRACK
PROGRAM AT UC SAN DIEGO.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARRIED THERE ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT.
KELLY BUCKS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS THE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
DOCTOR LAWRENCE MALLET FROM YOU
SEE S. SAN DIEGO ATTRACTIVE
BETWEEN THE TRACK AND ALSO IN
FULL SUPPORT.
TO MADDEN REPRESENT CALTRAIN
SHOP AT THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT.
HI JAMIE MCDONALD'S REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
OF WEST SAM'S WITH UNITED WAYS
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
HELLO DURING THE WISEMAN PRIVATE
CITIZEN ALSO A LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER THAT USED TO BE IN
CHILD WELFARE A TEACHER IN
CORRECTIONS FULL SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR BRENDA MARCH WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION.
WE APOLOGIZE WE DIDN'T GET A
LETTER INTO THE COMMITTEE.
WE DID HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
THE AT BILLS CURRENT LANGUAGE
BUT AFTER THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND WE ARE HAPPY TO
SAY THAT WAS PART OF A BILL.
NOW IT'S AUTHORED WITH A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
AND I ASSUME THAT.
PURE PURE THE WITNESSES AT THE
TABLE SUPPORTER AREN'T ARE NOT
I.
I THINK THEY'RE PRETTY
SUPPORTIVE OKAY PARA JUST JUST.
SURE OKAY VERY GOOD ABOUT ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR MISS MISAKI ARE
PER. I'M DELIGHTED WITH THIS
BILL SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING A
FOREIGN.
I STRUGGLE IN THESE RURAL
COMMUNITIES OF HAVING.
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH AND
PSYCHIATRY.
AND WE'VE HAD NUMEROUS
DEDICATIONS PARTICULARLY THIS
PAST YEAR IN NOW BUT THE
VETERANS HOSPITAL PSYCHIATRIST
ON STAFF.
WE'VE ALSO STRUGGLED IN LAKE
COUNTY. IN THE PSYCHIATRIST THAT
MOVED IN IN THIS. BUSTIN AND
WONDERFUL TO OUR COMMUNITY BY.
ACTUALLY UNTIL A PSYCHIATRY.
AND.
SO I'M FULL SUPPORT OF THIS.
AYE WHAT YOU KNOW NOW IT'S OKAY
TO COME TO RURAL AREAS I DON'T
NEED TO STAY ALONG IN THE AIR WE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO TAKE YOU IN.
REAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE.
AS WELL THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
AMEND THE BILL APPRECIATE THAT.
I COMPLETELY AGREE THAT WE NEED
MORE PSYCHIATRISTS AND
AND AS AS SOMEONE ELSE ALSO ALL
ECHO MISS SAGER CURRY'S COMMENTS
ABOUT RURAL COMMUNITIES.
I DOES I WILL SAY AS I SAY WITH
MR MATHIS EARLIER ON THAT YOU
HAVE RESERVATIONS ABOUT.
THE PROGRAM.
ONLY IN THAT IT IS
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND SO SO AS HE
SAID ON HIS WAY OUT THE DOOR
WE'LL BE LOOKING FOR MORE
FUNDING FOR THIS THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS BUT I DO HAVE.
RESERVATIONS SOME RESERVATIONS
OPENING UP TO A LARGER GROUP
WITHOUT KNOWING THAT IT'S OVER
SUBSCRIBED ALREADY BUT THAT THAT
BEING SAID I'M I I SUPPORT THE
BILL.
AND THAT WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
BY.
MISTER FLORA A SECOND I WAS AT
YOUR CURRY. AND A LAST MINUTE
SECTOR CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
ONE AYE TOILET AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE AGAR CURRY.
THANK YOUR CURRY AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA ALONE.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
CURRY I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE STEINORTH STEINORTH
LIKE THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WALDRON. WALDRON
AYE.
FIFTEEN SO THAT THAT BILL PASSES
UNANIMOUSLY. MISTER MAY CHECK
YOUR AFTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
SO THERE ARE NO BILLS ON CALL
BUT WE WILL MOVE TO THE TOP OF
THE AGENDA AND. TING ADDITIONAL
VOTES FOR THE
THE OUSTED.
SO.
THE BILL THAT PASSED ANYWAY
JUST.
SO.
THIS POINT WILL ASK A MADAME
SECRETARY THE OPEN THE ROLE FOR
ADDITIONAL VOTES ON AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE NUMBER ITEM NUMBER
ONE.
MISTER IS THERE IN THIS BILL.
STEINORTH.
MY NERVE I.
THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH IS.
ITEMS NUMBER THREE.
AB TWENTY ONE TWELVE CENTS IAGO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY FIVE MISTER VOEPEL ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY SEVEN MISTER BERMAN. ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT TWENTY THREE NINETY
SEVEN MISTER OBERNOLTE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY SIX MISTER MATHIS ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY ONE MISTER FLORA. AND ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
OH FOR MISS WALDRON.
AB PLEASE OPEN THE ROLAND CALLED
ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA. BONTA AYE
BURKE BURKE I LOAN LIMON AYE
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
RODRIGUEZ RHETORIC ASIDE
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO AYE STEINORTH
STAND RIGHT.
THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY THREE.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA. BONTA AYE
BURKE PER AYE LIMOS. LIMON AYE
MCCARTY MAYES MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN.
THIS AREA AND I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE.
THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN MISS
EGGMAN A PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA.
BONTA AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE STEINORTH. TIMER BY
FIFTEEN
THAT'S ALSO FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY DOCTOR ARAMBULA PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BONTA AYE BONTA AYE
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH AYE.
FIFTEEN ZERO.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY FOUR MISTER BLOOM PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BONTA BONTA AYE
CARILLO.
CARILLO I.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH AYE WALDRON.
FOURTEENTH ZERO.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY SIX MISS RUBIO
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA AYE BONTA
AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH AYE WALDRON.
THAT'S FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY NINE MISTER MATHIS
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA. BONTA AYE
BURKE BURKE AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY
AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE.
THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO AND THEN
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE MISTER KALRA
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA. BONTA AYE
BURKE BURKE I LIMON. LIMON I'M
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE RODRIGUEZ
RHETORIC ASIDE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH I.
THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO SO.
PLEASE IN GERMAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THINK WITH THAT WE WILL
CLOSE.
I MEAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH